uh good morning everyone and welcome to
this meeting of the mid-suffolk District
Council planning committee may I first
remind you all of some domestic
arrangements please ensure that
microphones are turned off when not in
use please do not interrupt other
speakers or hold separate conversations
or whilst others are speaking if you are
attending the meeting to speak and
persistently interrupt the meeting you
may be asked to leave
please ensure your mobile phones are on
silent or switched off and that your
laptops are switched to silent
I would also like to remind everyone
present that this meeting will be
broadcast live to the internet and will
be capable of repeated viewing the whole
of the meeting will be recorded except
where there are confidential or exempt
items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
recorded by entering this meeting as a
speaker you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council and the possible
use of those sound recordings for
webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the Press May record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the Press are not lawfully excluded
if you hear the fire alarm
leave the building immediately via a far
exit and make your way to the assembly
point at Ipswich Town Football ground
follow the signs directing you to the
far exits at each end of the floor do
not enter the atrium the ground floor
area and walkways if you are in the
atrium at the time of the alarm follow
the signs to the nearest fire exit use
the stairs not the lifts do not re-enter
the building until told it is safe to do
so
we now need some introductions
um
we have the um
area planning manager Gemma Walker we
have the
um no we don't have that person either
we have the legal advisor in to pray
well we will have case officers uh some
of whom will be um uh presenting uh
online and others will be in the
building we have governance officers
Claire Philpott Mandy Smith and Alicia
Norman
um we may also have some Ward members
who may either join us online or in
person and we have the members of the
committee who are sitting here this is a
new seating arrangement that we're
trying having the members on the
opposite side of the room so uh bear
with us if we're all look a bit confused
so I'd now like to move to the agenda
item number one is apologies for absence
and substitutions do we have any
apologies for absence
thank you chair we have apologies from
Council Austin Davies and councilor
David penny is substituting thank you
item number two to receive Declarations
of disclosable pecuniary interests and
other registerable or non-registerable
interests by members are there any to
declare
Council headingham
non-pecuniary I know that some of the
landowners
councilor wall boys did you want to make
a declaration
you know the landowners in two
of the applications
um John cousins and edwardling I
don't know them socially but I am
acquainted with them and I know to speak
to just to say if I cannot be heard
Madam chair the the two members are very
properly discussed this with me before
the meeting in the absolutely strict
sense under our latest regulations to
Suffolk code that all councils
encyclical adopted under localism Act
it's only a well there's a there's a
peculiar interest which it clearly isn't
there's an other registerable interest
it's things like unpaid directorships
and memberships of Charities it's only
really in in strict sense and
non-registerable interest if it's
a quote I'm quoting I've got the wording
here a relative or close associate but
very often when it's a contentious
matter
with public interest members really
appropriate to declare that they know an
applicant or a landowner or object and
that has been done so I'm quite content
members have done that properly and may
remain in the meeting
thank you
um item number three Declarations of
lobbying
um are there any to declare
um I think I think we've all been
lobbied on items two and three recently
uh I haven't received any lobbying for
item one this time round but we did get
lobbied
um a couple of months ago when it was on
the agenda so do we need to declare that
as well
yeah so um is that have we all
um been lobbied on items one two and
three
um Council Penny have you received any
of the emails
um and has anyone had any lobbying on
the other two items
no right um have you got all that uh
item number four Declarations of
personal site visits are there any to
declare
no item number five
um uh confirmation of the minutes of the
planning committee meeting held on the
16th of August uh now we've got a re
um a re-edited version in the late
papers which has had a couple of
Corrections in my rights
is that what is that the
yeah I did send an email yesterday it
was just a small correction changing the
word managers to members and one of the
um paragraphs
um and are there any points regarding
the accuracy of the minutes councilman
yes
um yeah it's um it seems to be regular
regular one somehow but the word
Renewables has been shortened down to
Renewal
um this is electronic page seven of the
supplement
value papers
um so it undoubtedly it should be energy
and Renewables integration scheme to be
agreed
um
I think it's been copy and pasted from
somewhere previously area manager
you said sorry it's in the um it's page
seven and it's in the reimpose the
following conditions from the outline
integration scheme and that was probably
the bullet point and I think we've
normally corrected that and confirmed it
should be renewable so that that
probably is how it's put in the
community court so I don't know where
we're going to correcting it but
certainly condition wise it will say
renewable
okay to the Future
I'll make that change and we'll vote on
it as with that change included
that's it any any other
um comments on the accuracy of the
minutes
um could I have a proposal please
to uh councilor harringham and councilor
hattingham are you seconding the minutes
do we do this as the electronic vote
yeah we'll do this as an electronic vote
please so I will um uh the government's
officer will now conduct the electronic
vote
thank you
thank you councilor Penny are you
oh it's okay it's just come through as
another day sorry thank you so that's
seven votes for one abstention
thank you so
um they meet minutes of the meeting have
now been confirmed I will be signed um
at the end of the meeting
um so item number six to receive
notification of petitions in accordance
with the council's petition scheme
thank you chair yes we have received a
petition and respect of application
dc2302118 there's 75 validated
signatures
petition reads as follows
we the undesigned petition the council
to refuse the Enzo frigo planning
application dc2302118
planning applications must be decided
according to the local plan and less
material considerations indicate
otherwise
this proposal is identical to the one
which was previously refused by
experienced counselors by a substantial
majority vote six to one in order to
protect the best and most versatile land
for the optimum purposes of Agriculture
and to protect the landscape character
and visual immunity at the valued
landscape forming part of the special
designated special landscape area the
users of the public right-of-way
community and tourists
in both respects the proposal was
contrary to the local plan as well as
the national planning policy framework
and the councils evidently did not
consider that there were any other
material considerations that indicated
that planning permissions should be
granted
the local plan still affords those same
protections as does the new as the mppf
new Publications and guidance by the
government still do not override their
local development plan environmental
concerns and the concerns of the local
community and so no new material
considerations have Arisen since the
previous refusal that would warrant a
change in decision
local development plans compiled over
many years and tailored to local
conditions are there to reflect the
wishes of the local community and ensure
consistency in planning decisions the
mid-suffolk local development plan still
provides those same protections to BMV
land landscape and immunity
however this application could also be
refused in order to protect the setting
of Heritage assets namely the grade one
listed St Mary's Church in floton a
non-designated Heritage asset of
floating Hall protect surrounding areas
from increased risks of flooding namely
the area of floating Brook to protect
skylarks which are a legally protected
bird to protect the immunity and safety
of public right-of-way users including
horse riders from glint and glare
unacceptable noise levels and fear of
harm due to high security fencing Heming
in the footpaths and Bridal ways and to
protect Public Safety and prevent harm
to the environment from pollution in the
event of a battery storage thermal
runaway fire event these are also all
material and all valid and material
planning considerations for refusal this
is an identical application and the
planning rules and guidance remain
unchanged the only change the political
makeup of the council and the planning
committee the planning committee decide
to override a legitimate substantial
majority decision it will clearly be due
to political reasons and not a change in
planning policy of substantial change in
the application
such such a dramatic change of decision
on political and not not planning
grounds would endanger all future
planning decisions as being tainted by
political rather than planning
considerations
please protect this Countryside and the
Integrity of the local development plan
by refusing application DC
23-02118 thank
you thank you
we now move to the
list of cases and we will stick to the
order as printed in the agenda so our
first application is
dc2302118 land to the south of church
Farm Summer and land to the east of the
channel birthstone and I will now invite
the case officer Braun Curtis to
introduce the application to the
committee of our teams thank you welcome
Ron
morning chair morning members thank you
very much
um so I'm going to just set out a few
um points of context because this is a
slightly unusual situation as you just
heard from that petition this
application is a duplicate of an
application that was determined by the
committee back in February
it is a solar proposal it is a cross
boundary application which means that
the application site straddles the
administrative boundary between baber
and mid-suffic districts
the application that went so the
applicant in that circumstance has to
make two duplicate submissions to each
determining Authority
the authorities have the choice
um under legislation to delegate their
powers of determination from one
authority to the other in this case
neither Council chose to do that which
means that each must make their own
decision on the application and the
applicant needs both decisions
to be granted in order to proceed with
the development as is shown
um the original application first went
to the baby Committee in February 8th of
February and that was granted planning
permission
the following week on the 15th of
February the application came before the
mid-suffolk planning committee and was
refused for two reasons the impact on
best and most versatile agricultural
land and the visual impact of the
development
um you have then also had the this
application scheduled for your meeting
on the 21st of June
that was subsequently pulled from the
agenda because we had identified an
admission administrative oversight in
terms of notifying the secretary of
state that it was eia development that
has now happened and the relevant
statutory period has has expired
but at that meeting on the 21st you did
consider
um another part of the recommendation
that was in that report which was to do
with the appeal so in the intervening
period after the refusal the applicant
exercise their right to appeal that
refusal to the Secretary of State that
appeared was running and we took
instruction from you
um once you'd heard advice from offices
and from legal council on how to proceed
with the appeal
that information that we gave you
included a summary of relevant appeal
decisions that had
um had been made since the February
decision
that document has been updated and can
be found in your tabled papers in
respect of item
7c on page 29 of your table papers it's
very similar to what you saw in June
there's been but there's been about
three additional decisions which I've
added to that and some of those
decisions are those which are cited by
the objector in the table papers for
item 7c which is why it's in there
what's also
um relevant to all three of the solar
items 7a7b 7c as well as that summary of
appeal decisions because those are
relevant to all and I'll let my my
colleagues speak
um to those in respect of item 7B if you
if she needs to but you also have as an
appendix to item 7A
a copy of the full appeal decision for
the enso appeal so that is the decision
of the planning inspector
to the appeal against the refusal that
the committee
um decided on at their meeting on the
15th of February so you can see that the
appeal was allowed and planning
permission has been granted for that
scheme so as it stands the scheme that
I'm about to present to you has got the
benefit of extant planning permission
from both baber and
um mid-suffered by virtue of the
planning inspector
um for the same scheme but just under
under different references so you the
applicant has a right also for what we
call a free go so the submission of the
same proposal by the same applicant on
the same site within 12 months of a
previous decision
um that is a right that all applicants
have we call it a free go because
there's no planning fee charged with
those submissions so that's why you will
see that terminology used in respect to
this application
also in your appendix I've written a
summary document which just picks out
some of the what I considered to be
quite interesting points of the appeal
decision but you've had the benefit of
reading the whole thing
um no doubt you may also have seen well
you will have had circulated the costs
decision that went with that
costs awarded against mid-suffolk
because of the decision just picking up
sorry before I get into the presentation
there's just a bit of context so just
picking up a point that came up in the
the petition that you just heard read
out
um decision precedent is material so the
previous decision is a material
consideration but as is the appeal
decision
and as are other appeal decisions and
other changes and circumstances which
you heard at the meeting on the 21st of
June which I will repeat to you very
briefly in a moment
um you may depart from a previous
decision but the reasons for doing so
must be clear and must be justified by
what is different
in the circumstances from that previous
decision
so what I had explained to you on at the
meeting on the 21st and what is in that
summary of appeals decision and in the
in your report for this application is
that there are circumstances in terms of
government
um publication powering up Britain Etc
and appeal decisions which set the tone
for the direction of travel for Solar
Development for the country which are
material and officers consider a
significant enough to um restate the
original recommendation to Grant
permission so that's where we are let me
show you the slides so that you can see
the scheme and refresh on what the
proposal is and where it is
so application site
which is this sort of y-shaped parcel it
has access from Churchill burstall
and is then adjoined by Highway called
the Channel
which comes up from floating and then
that road turns onto
um
Thailand which you can just see on the
top there
and you can also see here bramford
substation National Grid substation and
also the compound for the stanglia one
substation on the East Anglia 3
converter station under construction
that is just a more simple layout of the
plan you can also see a bit more clearly
on this plan where floating Brook lies
along that western boundary along more
or less along the route of the channel
Highway
she just heard about the petition
constraints map so
the site is within the designated
special landscape area
there is also an extent of flood zone
related to floating Brook
and you can see the rights of way
Network which cross
to and through the site
in terms of Rights of wine right away
this plan shows the best and most
versatile
agricultural land classifications so the
colors show the different splits of
grades with blue being grade two
the darker green being grade 3A and the
lighter green being grade 3B so you can
see for them and this also has the
administrative boundaries which is the
black line so you can see that this
parcel here
is in mid-suffolk
the rest of the
the site is in baber the cable route
which is undergrounded is is in a little
bit of both but you can see that for the
purposes of the mid-suffic extent of the
site we have grade two and grade 3A so
that is all best and most versatile land
just a bit more detail on the special
landscape area designation
so that you can see the baby designation
there in green and the mid-suffic area
relating to your policy cl2 in blue
I've included this slide because this
application is eia development and was
screened in on the basis of the
potential for cumulative effects given
the other proposed developments that are
currently in
um with the with planning at the moment
so the site that you're considering with
this application is this y-shaped parcel
here
these cross hatch parcel is an
application known as either stackcraft
or Gray Barn which sits just a little
further up Thailand but obviously it
joins the site here as you can see and
this hatched site is the EDF site which
is actually your item 7c that you'll be
considering later this morning
and you can see how they sit overall in
the landscape and well relative to
communities
this is the plan that shows the layout
of the development with split amongst
three fields
five and six being predominantly baber
and four with a tiny bit of five being
in mid-suffolk you've also got a
compound for battery storage and
substation Etc equipment with this
proposal so there is battery as well as
generation
you can also see in this plan the roots
of designated rights arrive but also
permissive routes that's the pink and
permissive Bridal way which passes
between Fields four and five and then
down to the channel
a bit more detail on the layout there
and you can see some of the landscape
mitigation
layout of the substation and battery
storage complex
a bit more detail on landscape ecology
enhancement
plans are the solar strings
and the other equipment
I'm going to Rattle through this a
little bit because I know you've seen it
a couple of times but do let me know if
you want to go back to anything an
example of the fencing so the majority
of the site to be enclosed by
stockproof fencing
and the battery compound to being closed
by a slightly closer gauge wire mesh
fencing
or security purposes there was some
concern raised about the visual impact
of those
those fencing inclusions
so just going through the photographs
the access there from Churchill burstal
you can just see a sign here for UNESCO
so there is a battery storage
development that has been
constructed which uses the same access
and he's close to close to the site for
this development
This Is A View From the channel
um on the west side of the site looking
towards the site so you can just see the
incline of the site above the road and
the river you can just see this
culverted section where the river runs
down in that in that channel there
this is the main view from the western
side the rest of the site is pretty well
screened and enclosed by mature
vegetation the road is very narrow
there's not really a lot of opportunity
for other views except for this this
field access which is also the
permissive right away route
and then turning around onto the channel
on the Northern side as it comes around
the bend This Is A View From the right
of way you can just see the finger post
there so looking towards the site
Southwest the field um six being at the
top behind the trees there
and then just turning around so that you
can see this field in the foreground is
subject to the stack craft proposal but
in the background
behind that field would be where
um the the rest of the development would
be where the battery storage and
substation compound is
and then some views from the rights of
way through the site
you can just get a sense of the
enclosure of the site and also some of
the other
um features in the landscape such as the
pylons Etc
and some of the wider views so from the
rights of way looking northwards
and again slightly wider views coming
out further
on the site so that you get a sense of
where the site sits within the landscape
was asked to included this last time so
I'll just go over this again that we
have
um the expectation of the development
would be that it would produce the
equivalent electricity usage for
approximately seven and a half thousand
homes each year and save
um just over six thousand tons of CO2
each year
that is the end of the presentation
thank you
um so are there any questions from
members uh councilor Mathison
thank you chair
um yeah there's there's two um
two things that perhaps we've taken one
at a time I wanted to just understand
exactly the
what the administrative oversight was
and what the consequences of that were
that's question one
okay so the application is eia
development and so
um it is necessary to consider the
provisions of the eia regulations in
terms of the processing of such an
application regulation 19 of that
legislation requires that we notify the
Secretary of State of any eia
development so they have the chance to
to review and consider whether they want
to step in and take any action and
then a subsection of Regulation 19 says
that we can't make a decision on such an
application until six weeks from the
date of that notification has passed and
we hadn't sent that email
that email was was subsequently sent
um around that I think it was around the
19th of June
so the six weeks has passed and we've
had we've had confirmation of receipt
from Secretary of State and that they're
not taking any action
was that okay uh would you like your
second question yeah yeah the other
question
um can we have a look at that slide
seven which is the um the the other
um what's effectively the one that's on
the screen only we need to get it a bit
bigger
um
oh that's it
yeah so yeah the question essentially
was whether the um
you know this is obviously this is about
the sort of community being well yeah
Community
cumulative impact sorry
um
the the status of these schemes
um the other schemes and
um
whether whether that situation has
changed
um well I suppose the important one will
be between June and September
the main material change is that the
existing site now has planning
permission
granted from both
um effectively both authorities so the
baby permission out right and then the
Mid-South at permission by virtue of the
allowed appeal the stackcraft gray Bond
application remains in and under
consideration it's at it's not at a
particularly Advanced stage in terms of
responding to original consultation so
we're expecting further information from
them in a further round of consultation
before it can is in a fit state to be
presented to committee
the EDF site is your item 7c on today's
agenda
uh does that answer your questions
councilmanson uh does anyone else have
any questions councilor penny
um
do you agree
enough
potentially enough roof rooftop space
to provide
the government's Target of 770 gigawatts
as required in the power up written
document
that is a really difficult question to
answer because it's not just about the
amount of roof that might be available
but the capability and the structural
Integrity of that roof to take
solar and also then what happens with
that solar generation in terms of
whether it's on-site consumption and
storage or whether it's leading to the
grid because there's plenty of roof
that's not particular not as well
connected as it might be
we've got the powering up Britain is
clear that ground-mounted solar plays a
part in achieving that zero and that the
expectation is a five-fold increase in
the existing installation of ground
mounted solar
to 70 gig by 2035 just to put that into
context the current land take for solar
at the moment across the UK is about 0.1
percent
of land if we achieve the 70 gig that
will take it to about 0.3
0.0.3 percent of all land in the UK
um putting that into other contexts
about uh 50 or so of the land the UK is
used for farming
and actually more than 0.3 is used for
golf courses and that always seems a
little bit of a
sort of a funny comparison but it's a
fact that there is more Landing use for
golf courses than there is currently or
would be with the Net Zero targets
covered by solar
figure is reached then
no no more solar ground mounted solar
applications will be allowed
again a difficult question because
you're asking me to talk about
government policy which I don't play any
cars in I just use it as a tool to to do
the work that we do
it may be that when we get to the Target
of 70 Gig if we get there that we're
looking at what the net zero and other
climate change statistics are at the
point at that point in time and we need
something else it's a fact that we
haven't had any new offshore generation
installed this year or permitted this
year that's not on target with what the
government objectives are
so there is a mix of
um energy security and solar is part of
that but there's plenty of other
micronuclear hydrogen and offshore wind
as well as onshore wind so I think
it's it's thus too difficult sorry I'm
not answering the question because it's
too difficult to answer precisely
Suffolk once we reach the 0.3
um
a similar question and what percentage
locally are we at now
I don't have the statistics for Suffolk
that was asked earlier this week and I
did try and find out I was speaking to
colleagues at County who are dealing
with Seneca to see if it came up in
their discussion we don't have that
information available it's it's probably
something that we can do a bit of maths
on and find out for another time
um if you'd like us to
I think the thing to remember is that
this the the targets are not set on a
county level
Net Zero is a national objective
um and
there are parts for all for all
communities within the country to play
in that
the energy generated by this particular
proposal and the other two proposals
that you're going to be seeing this
morning are to be connected to
the distribution and transmission
Network that means it will benefit
everybody that is plugged into the grid
wherever they are in the country there
are schemes that as I said earlier might
have consumption on site the storage on
the site that's possible there's plenty
of people that have solar on their own
roofs and they generally use the energy
generate for that for their own purposes
with a little bit of feeding perhaps
but on the these schemes here we'll go
into the grid so they have the benefit
of powering homes
um in this case we have around uh I
think I said 14 000 times putting that
into context with the communities that I
hear the communities of Branford burst
or floating and submission put together
are around 1100 homes so you've then got
plenty of that generating capacity that
might go to schools hospitals businesses
there's no way of controlling the
consumption unless you are directly
plugged into the source of generation
goes to the grid and and and most of us
are connected to the grid
okay uh
Council hardingham
um just to put a little bit of context
around the amount of land being used
um and put
to have a look at the best and most
versatile land as well we're looking at
constantly comparing the amount of land
being taken up by one of these solar
Farms with the total agricultural land
area in the UK most of which is going to
give you grade 3B 4 5. so could we have
a look more closely to what the area of
grade two or three a land is
which is the land which really produces
most of the food and the calorific value
that we eat and rely on
so I can refer you to the Enzo appeal
decision that's in your appendix
um and I've I've given a bit of
commentary on that in the report that
you've got for this item because it's
the same scheme in which the inspector
describes the the way in which
agricultural land
classification is understood so we have
the information from defra which is very
general it's a very large scale and it's
it's not particularly qualified or
detailed you can see from the report
that that initial information was
telling us that that
um something and then you get
site-specific soil surveying and
sampling which then gives more precise
detail about the makeup of the site
the because the majority of mid-suffolk
is
um grade two or three the inspector says
that it's around 97 I think he says
is probably
um best and most versatile or has the
potential to be because it's grade two
or three so this is actually a really
tiny proportion of that overall
amount of land that's in
mid-suffolk asbnb
um any further questions from members
uh councilor okin
um
I just wanted to follow up I think uh
councilor hardingham's point was that
sort of Suffolk is blessed with quite a
lot of
high-grade agricultural land so the fact
that it's only uh the the fields that
we're looking at is a relatively small
portion of suffolks best of most
versatile land we've actually got a
decent chunk of the UK's BMV land I
think so
um
I think that was the point
um if I've understood correctly so that
would be a useful statistic at some to
know um but my question was you when in
your presentation you you mentioned that
obviously colleagues previously have
refused permission for this
um and you said that for us to find
differently there needs to be a reason
something needs to have changed and
obviously the appeal is one key issue
but I just wondered if you could
highlight for us in your mind what you
think the key changes are between when
this was heard last time and now
so I've summarized those for you in the
report in the principal section and
um the the key differences since the
decision that was taken in February the
publication of powering up Britain and
the energy security strategy that's
included in there which restates the
five-fold increase in ground mounted
solar and the 70 gig by 2035 Target
and then a series of appeal decisions so
I picked out some which are are probably
most relevant which are in your report
but also in your tabled papers at page
29 I've updated that summary of other
appeal decisions some allowed some
dismissed but which give you the context
of how the mood nationally is going
and the direction of travel for solar
decisions
um and you will remember the advice that
you had from Council in respect of those
decisions when we were considering
um how to proceed with the appeal
against that refusal
um so all that information is is before
you again today the other thing that is
worth noting about BMV which I've
detailed in the report is that
um
the application is for a Time limited
permission of 40 years
there is the capability of the site to
be used there is a new term Agri
voltaics so a concurrent Agricultural
and generation use so for grazing
basically between panels that is
possible there was also the inspector
found the evidence
of the agricultural land witness at the
inquiry to be very compelling in terms
of the benefits of the development to
the ongoing safeguarding and quality of
the soil what they've what they
concluded was that actually the
development taking it out of active
production and just keeping low-level
grazing as well as the development would
improve the soil quality and maintain
that for future Generations at the end
of the development so the recommendation
before you includes the time limitation
on the planning permission the
decommissioning and reinstatement of the
site so it's returned to its existing
state plus the retention of the
biodiversity net gain and Landscape
mitigation improvements but also a soil
management condition
so that we can control
um an assurance of the quality of the
soil across the lifetime of the
development and at the end of the
development
thank you I think it's just well for me
I'm sure for all of us it's sort of the
the various appeals some are finding in
favor of protecting BMV land and some
are prioritizing
powering up Britain and the need for
more Renewables and there's a mix of
both so there isn't as you say the
direction of travel seems to be favoring
Renewables over BMV but it's not 100
clear-cut so
um just in terms of being sure we have
that
difference that you said we need to look
for so thank you
uh councilor Lawrence
yes I'm trying to get my head around
this particular application
my understanding is
that
they already have permission for this
identical
application we're now looking at
so why hasn't the applicant withdrawn
this free go application or we were
requested of the freego application is
it to me it seemed a bit irrelevant to
this today because they have the
permission
if I may help on that the you're quite
right councilor Lawrence the um the
applicant has planning permission given
by this planning inspectors Secretary of
State
well that strictly speaking it's still
in theory vulnerable to a possible legal
challenge in the for a period of six
weeks I'm just looking at the date on
the appeal 29th of August
so for a period of six weeks 42 days
there's a theoretical possibilities
somebody could bring a high court
challenge to it under Section 288 of the
planning Act
um and we I think doing some rough maths
that takes us to about the 11th of
October so I suppose it's worth their
while
given that this application is sometime
overdue as it were and
um
we ought to be determined by the council
that it is worth their while not to
withdraw it until
and you come back on that basis then is
it worth referring this decision on this
particular application until after that
the date
I would advise Nosa I'm sure Bron would
concur with that that we the council has
a duty to determine planning
applications that are made to it
there's often the
and there are time limits and we often
go well beyond them with with or without
the agreements of the applicant because
particularly when they go to committee
we have to prepare them we have a
sometimes have a queue of applications
committee doesn't
doesn't so I I think I'll I'll hand over
to rob in a moment but my advice is it's
our duty to determine it and this is we
we had a delay
um we were hoping to determine this on
the 20 was it the 21st or 23rd of June
uh
yeah indeed well on a previous date and
we we have for because we realize
they've been administrative error we had
to advise to to defer it so I I think my
advice is we ought to go ahead and I'll
hand over to Bron in case she has any
and and it's it's not that unusual we
have had other cases similar
umatis where but I guess it's I guess
it's the up to the applicant it's their
decision but maybe Bron can Enlighten us
thank you chair
um not a great deal to add um Mr dupres
covered it really there within their
right to make this submission it it we'd
get it quite commonly it is often known
as twin tracking where you have two
schemes whichever which are either the
same or very similar
um applicants are within their rights to
make as many applications to us
um for for schemes sometimes they are
alternative schemes that they just start
choosing between if there's something
slightly different in this case there
isn't anything different
um I wouldn't
advise delaying a decision on this
there's no reason to do that in my mind
thank you uh any further questions from
members
if not we'll move on to the public
speakers and I think we have first
Branford Parish Council Caroline Walton
if you'd like to press the button on
your
microphone and you've got three minutes
and I will time you with my high-tech
timer
left or right or right there we go
Brampton Parish Council
Deliverance application and understand
is identical to DC
2005895 which at planning committee
meeting on the 15th of February 23 was
refused permission by a large majority
of the panel it including two councilors
here today promptly Enzo registered both
an appeal against the decision and this
identical application
the elections happened we hope the new
fight to protect some of our finest
farmland and special landscape area as
laid out in their policies
the pointingly democracy was pushed
aside and closed meetings and poor
communication followed mid-suffolk
District Council and the green party
abandoned its communities stating that
it did not wish to defend the reasons
for refusal and therefore did not object
to the appeal application resulting in
the appeal being allowed and the
planning permission being granted
as you have heard the inspector
subsequently allowed the appeal granting
planning permission but not without
condemning the decision not to defend it
he stated the original refusal was
reasonable and for valid reasons but the
reasons for not defending that refusal
were unreasonable awarding full costs
against the council Brantford Parish
Council are extremely disappointed in
the outcome and still urge you to refuse
this application and stand fast with
your previous decision
as a result of your decision in the
appeal even the inspector hinted at your
predetermination of this application for
approval we ask that you follow the
advisory comments of the appeal decision
ensuring all the conditions recommended
by the inspector are actioned as part of
this application to protect our
environment and Community we
particularly wish to see the Skylark
mitigating strategy strategy implemented
before any development work commences
Brantford Parish Council accepts the
need for and supports renewable energy
however not at any cost and disregard to
the community hosting it Brantford is
being consumed by development and now
threatened by solar industrialization by
the number of proposed energy projects
dominating the surrounding landscape
these will have a devastating effect and
at a huge cost to the local environment
no attempt has been made to ensure solar
panels are on the rooftops of our
multiple large industrial units and new
home developments nearby yet it appears
it is okay to remove the best and most
versatile land from our crop production
to provide more power we can survive
with less electricity but not without
food this does not follow the green
party's new energy policy
the environmental impact and loss of
agricultural land caused by this
application appears disproportionate to
the amount of energy being produced the
loss of 35 hectares of Greenfield arable
agricultural land in the gipping valley
special landscape area most being best
and most versatile to power only seven
and a half thousand homes is madness
this application undermines government
intent to protect such land National
policy states this should be avoided for
development and low land used instead
yet none has been considered we ask you
to refuse this application here today
for these reasons thank you
thank you do we have any questions from
members to the parish council
representative
thank you very much
I now have an objector Mr Gary page if
you would like to press a button on your
microphone and you'll have your three
minutes
a different
okay I'm sorry could I just clarify I
was told I had three minutes but it
you're saying it's two no three it's
three sorry it's really hard to hear
here and and I didn't hear anything
about the petition so I apologize if I'm
repeating things and I'll try not to
repeat the clerk did read out
um the petition
yeah I I couldn't hear it oh okay sorry
sorry it's at the cue sticks so um okay
away
um I live in floton less than half a
mile from this development and I and
hundreds of others and all our Parish
councils oppose it I'm trying to cut my
notes out here
um not to duplicate what uh councilors
said but I and my fellow following the
June meeting
secret you were persuaded not to defend
the appeal decision and I and my fellow
residents were left to defend your
decision at appeal with no money to pay
for a barrister
sadly we were not able to convince the
inspector to uphold your decision
despite highlighting the errors and
emissions
and naturally the appellants Barrister
didn't say anything and neither did did
ours the inspector said the original
decision in February was reasonable and
I'm asking you to make the same
reasonable decisions again
the inspectors actually criticized as
subsequent decisions at your June
meeting which he's uh classified as
quote unreasonable behavior leaving
you'll understand why we're angry and
the same experts are now recommending
acceptance of the Enzo application and
the EDF application which is even more
intrusive
like the cancer there I'm not sure why
Enzo are continuing with this because
they've already got planning permission
we haven't got the money to challenge
this in in an inspection hearing
inspectors here
the development will go ahead but I'm
asking you to make it clear that you're
posing and to reject similar
applications
the inspector States in his rep is
consideration is whether benefits
presented in support of the scheme
outweigh any harms identified I argue
they don't they're a minimal or no
benefits in solar farms in Suffolk apart
from for multinational Banks developers
and landowners there are 1.4 million
homes in Suffolk Essex and Cambridge
here and the Suffolk offshore wind farms
produce enough electricity for
coincidentally 1.4 million homes
in size will be another 2.5 million
homes and they Supply it for 99 of the
time edfs uh solar figures which I'm
having to rely on are rates of 11 to 12
because obviously it's dark 50 of the
time generation in of electricity in
Suffolk will increase substantially size
will be six million homes there'll be
more electricity going through Brantford
than the National Grid infrastructure
can currently cope with and you're aware
of
um the uh plans to build more we do not
we should not be producing this
electricity for the rest of Britain a
recent TV program about Suffolk and
Norfolk called as the Bread Basket for
Britain because of our food production
the harms are laid out in your February
decision and the inspector's report on
the character and appearance of the
countryside including the public rights
away heritage site and the loss of BMV
land
almost at the end yes if you decide to
do your final sentence that's fine yep
um I my colleague said about agreeing
the planning conditions which were set
out with um by the inspector and
ensuring that they are in for enforced
to the fullest and not watered down or
ignored I'm happy to answer questions
and thank you for your tolerance thank
you do we have any questions of Mr Page
thank you very much
um we now have a supporter John cousins
do we have a supporter John cousins yeah
right if you'd like to
um press the button and you'll have
three minutes thank you very much I'm
going to be fairly brief
I'm here to obviously answer any
questions should there be any
um six years ago I started talking to
Enzo it's been a pretty fascinating
interesting and highly bruising
experience
I don't feel that I'm particularly
welcome at the Harvest supper anymore in
the village
um and it's and it's a very emotional
thing this whole proposal I'm going to
comment very briefly about three
particular areas BMV
there's an expression that I think you
all know live as though you are going to
die tomorrow Farm as though you were
going to live forever
my view is that this solar project is
temporary
my view as bronze suggested is that at
the end of 40 years this will be this
land will be returned to production
and I'm confident that my family who are
all in their 30s and my daughter's with
me today and my sons they will see this
land brought back into production it
won't be ruined it won't be
commercialized it won't be factories it
will be land back in production secondly
Wildlife much has been said about
Wildlife Wildlife damage my view is I'm
turning a field of wheat which is
hostile to Wildlife
particularly insects and small mammals
hostile to Wildlife into an area that's
beneficial for wildlife I've spent my
working life working for the environment
I was director of agricultural policy
for the Wildlife trust UK for 20 years
I'm a former chairman of the Suffolk
Wildlife trust now the only reason I say
that is I want to express that I take my
environmentally in my environmental
responsibilities incredibly seriously
Skylark mitigation
yes I've got numerous pairs of skylarks
because I've worked for 40 years to get
them there and I am not going to have 40
years work
producing skylarks go out the window
because of solar panels I will make it
work
and the last comment I'm going to make
is about the visual aspect and this is
the Achilles heel this is what is is so
disappointing about solar is that it is
having an impact on
the landscape
my hedges are 20 to 30 feet tall and
they will stay that tall and I hope that
Within
very few years people will see that this
solar project isn't as bad as they fear
isn't as bad as they've been told and
they will accept that it's a necessary
element of our fight against climate
change and it's worth doing it now thank
you very much
thank you are there any questions of Mr
cousins
uh councilor Elkin
thank you um I just wanted to ask you
mentioned the sort of the mitigation and
Views and that you have very high Hedges
at the moment in terms of landscaping
that's going to be used for this if this
development goes ahead
um could you just explain briefly what
you're planning to do I know we've seen
in in the details but um it'd be great
to hear from you what you're what you're
planning to do and how to make the
impact on rights of way users as minimal
as possible indeed thank you well you
have seen the plans of what Enzo are
proposing I will go way beyond that I
took I took 15 Acres of arable land out
of production 30 years ago to plant
Woodland that Woodland is now
really you could say almost semi-mature
30 40 feet high and it's a fantastic
feature in the landscape I'm going to go
on planting trees it is my passion I
won't see those trees 40 feet tall but
my family will and I think that you know
this project is part of my overall
policy on the farm I've already taken 80
acres of arable land out of production
to go into pollen and nectar and and
winter bird food for birds so I take the
point about food production but there is
a huge drive in this country for the
environment and biodiversity and
awareness that we are destroying
biodiversity as we speak
thank you any further questions uh thank
you Mr cousins uh we now have the
applicant Owen horrell
um if you'd also like to have your three
minutes you can press the button on your
microphone
good morning I will keep my comments
relatively brief
as outlined this is an application which
seeks planning permissions which is
identical to the scheme which is
recently
recently as detailed in the offices
report and in the inspector's decision
there are no planning reasons to refuse
this application
proving this application members of this
committee are able to attach the
conditions suggested by officers which
was not included in the appeal decision
that being the condition was suggested
regarding the soil management plan and
also make a local decision on the
application
I'll be pleased to answer any questions
you may have
thank you any questions
councilor Mathison
yeah I I just wanted to ask that legal
advisor if if that's right that we we
can actually add conditions
um to the appeal decision
yeah yes because well you this is this
is a different it's an identical
planning application but it's different
you can make whatever this decision
appears to you appropriate and I'm from
what I've heard I've been told I wasn't
present at the planning inquiry myself
but my Miss curses Braun will confirm I
think and I don't think Jeremy you went
there were you no but that the there was
discussion about this condition the
applicant appeared to
hear to Representatives Council appeared
to be happy with it but it looks like a
no an oversight by the inspector from
what I'm being told and it's
um there's no reason legal reason why
you shouldn't impose it today
particularly in the light of the fact
the applicants indicated
councilor Lawrence
I'm still trying to get my head around
this double application first
um
you end up with two consents presumably
if that happens and you have different
conditions only either consent
so on what basis then do you pick and
mix what you want to take it seems to
rather be a bit of a duplication and
being a little bit cynical and I find
that I'm struggling with it
I'll help if I
if I um
where you have two planning permissions
which I don't if that may be the result
of the decision that you'll make shortly
I don't know is up to members but if
that is the results of the decision
then yes in theory the applicant can
choose which one to implement
but I don't know I don't want to put the
applicant on the spot but they
if they're indicating their willingness
to agree to this condition I'm I'm
drawing the inference that they will
they will that if if permissions granted
that they will
there be no point in them saying that if
they didn't intend to
um
imply with a condition
you can come back can we condition then
that they use this application and not
the previously granted one no no I'm
afraid not sorry
uh any further questions uh councilor
War boys
oh yes thank you thank you chair uh yeah
it's um I've just had a quick look at
the planning inspectors
um decision and just for clarification
uh my interpretation of this the council
was found to be acting unreasonable
because it didn't bring forward this
application quickly enough because if
you
determine this application and approve
the application an appeal wouldn't have
been necessary
it's on page
two paragraph 10.
I don't know whether whether Gemma or
Ian can help us out here
it's where I didn't quite follow the
question well I just wanted to clarify
we
it's been suggested we were acting
unreasonable by not defending the
previous decision uh
from what the inspector says my
interpretations were found to be acting
unreasonable because we didn't bring
forward this application fast enough in
order to preventive appeal
that's correct so essentially if we had
having decided as we did that we weren't
going to defend it the reasonable thing
to do would then be to say okay we've
got this other application in it's
running we can determine it and
essentially what would likely to have
happened at AMR stepping here with the
appeal presses is the appeal would then
be withdrawn is sort of the usual
process avoiding the unreasonable and um
um costs on behalf of the applicant and
not doing so was part of the
unreasonable in this year
thank you
any further questions uh thank you um uh
we
oh sorry councilor penny
I don't know if I'm allowed to ask this
but um
I'm going to ask Ian
if we had appealed the decision what
would our chances of success have been
in his legal opinion
or of Defending we have defended the the
refusal yes well I think I'm not I would
struggle to give you a full answer in
Open Session Council Penny I think your
colleagues most of you were here in June
and you read in closed session the
advice about
our leading Council distinct Mr Cosgrove
KC on the prospects of success
that that's legally privileged as we
have to stick to the decision to read
that in closed session
um at least in the short term
that I think I don't think I can say
much more than that Madam chair unless
you feel you read that decision too that
opinion too yeah I mean you don't know
what's going to happen it's
um
had we defended it we don't know what
the outcome would have been it may have
been exactly the same or Worse we don't
know so we we took legal advice which
said that it it wasn't prudent to do so
but you can never foretell the future
can you you know if you can't say what
if you don't know what would have
happened
sometimes gone into
sometimes you go into court inquiry
thinking
thinking miracles happen but I mean I
think you have to make a decision based
on the advice that is available
best advice available at the time Gemma
thank you I was just I think Braun might
have wanted to add to that um
just
to add that we have been working closely
with the community who were previously a
rule six party to the appeal which means
that they they are registered as an
interested party and had a right to
um to participate in the appeal and that
there was a decision about the
processing of the previous this
application previously
so as to not undermine their case at
appeal so there is a balance that we
considered in chicken and egg as it were
what which was going to happen first
given the timeline of the appeal the
community subsequently pulled out as a
rule six but they were still invited to
participate
um actively in the inquiry and put their
points to the inspector so
officers as I say had had
extensive dialogue with representatives
of the community you will have seen the
um
the public statement that was put out on
behalf of both mid-suffolk and
and uh kerosava the community in respect
of the appeal and that that was the
reason
that we decided not to determine not to
push determination of this application
sooner so as not to Prejudice the
position of the community to do what
they are entitled to do in participating
in the appeal notwithstanding the fact
that the council had decided to take
their own position which was different
thank you
um so if if we now move on I see the
board member uh Council James Caston are
you here to make any representation
okay uh so I'd now like to open up this
for debate
anybody like to make a start
counselor penny
okay I just like to say that our hands
seem to be tied by a government policy
here and um
I very much sympathize with the
residents and the representative of
Barham Parish Council
um ideologically
I would like to see a different set of
government priorities with priorities
for such solar systems to be on rooftops
because nationally it is possible to do
this it's just
ideologically our national government
has a different
ideology and they've had 13 years in
power to sort out a
Linked UP sensible plan to avoid such
ins applications and situations as this
where there is a mad Panic to cover our
green and present land with solar panels
but
from the point of view of material
planning considerations our hands seem
to be very much Tied by government
policy central government policy on this
[Music]
um
rather than what green party policy
would be which would be to defend our
green and present land and enrich
biodiversity
thank you
thank you yes
um I mean there's several several points
I wanted to make I think the
um you know coming back to the
the points from the from the parish
Council and the objector
um
you know the the
the change from February and I was party
to the decision in February
and I voted for refusal
um you know Green Party policy is
clearly not not changed
um we we have the same view about this
thing it's important to say so and
you know what has changed I think apart
from the the context
is the um
is is that the government has made it
clearer and clearer over those ensuing
sort of eight months whatever it is now
um that that it's it's it's it's
sets Primacy by
of moving forward with renewable energy
and so I agree with what council the
penny has said clearly about the
rooftops and so on absolutely we would
like to see that there I I think the the
points that uh Mr Page made about the
um you know the capacity of of the grid
to to deal with all this electricity
um I think you know that that is that is
an interesting point now what I found
was interesting was to if you analyze
the three applications that we've got
before us and and accept the
um the sort of broad calculations about
how many thousand homes each of these
would
um would Supply and it's not clear
whether that's Supply at current levels
of demand or Supply at the level when
we've all got um we've got our heat
pumps working we've got our electric
cars and so on
um that you know these three would
provide roughly 50 of the electricity
for me to Suffer Well that's quite
interesting and there's another one
coming along
to commit you in the month month or
two's time which will you know add
considerably to that even more
but
if you go back a few decades you you
find a time when
Britain was electricity was being
supplied by coal mines and the coal
mines were having a great impact in a
small number of places and and the the
big problem
is transmitting the electricity around
the country and
um the the grid are now
struggling not very well to to to solve
the problem that the the north-south
um
transmission that they had has suddenly
turned out to be not what's needed and
what we actually need is a completely
different setup which transmits it from
the North Sea and and and size well to
the rest of the country and there's a
there's a there's another separate
argument which we will be having at some
point
about
to what extent Suffolk should be should
be um
impacted by the transmission issue
um but that's a separate issue if we're
going to be one of the energy producers
of the
the country well fair enough
we will do we will do that but how it's
transmitted that is a issue that's not
in front of us today at all and so I I
just would finally say that the
the factor apart from the the decisions
the factor that has changed from
February to June to September is that
I've got a better understanding of what
Mr cousins has been talking about that
you you can actually get a significant
biodiversity gain
while the panels are there for that 35
or 40 years so I I think that's the the
thoughts that I have about it and and it
you know it's it's not about the change
of political control
that's that's a separate story that
hasn't changed
how we think in this chamber as a
planning committee
uh thank you
um if I'd actually like to to um uh
follow on from councilor Mathison I too
was part of that uh committee back in
February and I too voted for refusal
um and I too like councilor Mathison
have learned since then about the
benefits of the biodiversity
um and there are the material changes in
terms of the decisions that have already
been made I also felt very strongly
about the loss of grade two
um land in fact I probably spoke about
that in February
um and and now we have an appeal
decision which basically says it doesn't
matter that it was great to land because
I know although with Suffolk may be
considered the Bread Basket we don't
have very much grade two land we have
significant amounts of grade 3A but as I
understand it we don't have a lot of
grade two and that was what upset me
back in February but now I I read an
appeal decision which basically puts
that to bed and says that doesn't really
matter
um and and yes I understand now that
there is a biodiversity net gain by
putting solar panels on what was
previously an arable field but what does
strike what hasn't been mentioned is
after 40 years we've got this wonderful
biodiverse solar farm and we take it
down and and surely we'll then have a
biodiversity loss if we put it back into
wheat Fields again but I guess that's
the problem we come to at the end of the
cycle
but there has been material changes and
and material decisions
um I still feel quite sad about the loss
of grade two land but it looks like that
it doesn't count for much anymore
and I do understand
um the the concerns of the community
um but there are lots of other changes
that have been been made even within my
lifetime that were probably you know we
didn't like them then it it's nobody
likes change and yet we do actually have
an industrial Heritage
um okay maybe it goes back a long time
that we now consider in parts of the
country industrial Heritage is part of
the scenery I'm not saying that solar
Farms are going to look delightful but
they might be interesting
um to look at they'll be different and
maybe we have to learn to accept them
just like we've accepted lines of pylons
across the countryside
and other other things that we rely on
um you know nobody likes pylons and yet
we look at them every day and we
probably ignore them so maybe something
will happen you know in the next 40
years and we'll we'll change our view I
don't know but um
I'm I'm not you know I'm quite open to
say that yes I refused it I was happy to
refuse it back in February but I think
things have changed and maybe we've
moved on a bit both from a government
point of view and and from our own
learning point of view but I'll let
anyone else have something to say
Council Lawrence and then I've got
cancer out
I just I think the main thing that
changed is the
bluntness of it
of it I don't see that that
um then impacts necessary on the next
two solar applications that we're going
to consider after this so I don't want
to mix up put all three in the same pod
so I think we should use the opportunity
here now to impose extra conditions on
this planning application and hope that
the applicant takes them on board and I
doesn't use the one that he's already
got
I didn't quite catch up you're saying we
should oppose this no oh
what I'm saying is that
will take the opportunity
on extra condition
and hope that the applicant takes on
board this application for consent and
preference to the previous one
thank you uh count
ing
um
it's just
it's a really tricky one I mean as
everybody else has said our hands feel
fairly tied
um there's been change in government
priorities and policy I mean
as a green party member and I think but
across parties I think all of us would
rather see solar panels on roofs I mean
it's just logical to make sense
um but that's not what we're being asked
to consider
um unfortunately
um and we find ourselves with the cost
of living crisis where we need
affordable food we've got a biodiversity
crisis and we've got a the climate
crisis so we've got these competing
tensions
um which we need to deal with and it
feels like projects like this
whether we feel happy about them in
particular locations
it contributes to the biodiversity
crisis by leaving land set aside
ads renewable so you know I feel really
we all live in rural communities I
always start by thinking how would I
feel if this was outside my window
um or on the lanes that I walk in
um and so for me I do feel our hands are
tied and I would hope that we could have
um if we were able to add conditions
make sure that
Hedges are planted that the the rights
of way footpaths are screened as well as
they can be in as effectively as they
can be for Walkers who are still going
to be using this Countryside so yeah
it's a it's difficult and I do have
sympathy with with the people who live
in this community
uh thank you um so I'm not sure we've
actually had any four more proposals uh
yet
um but does anyone else want to speak uh
councilor hardingham
councilor War boys
yeah yes
uh
yes it's been a bit of an expensive
um process sort of
making one decision and then um as it
were almost recanting on that decision
in the light of clarification of uh
government policy and more information
but I think it's been a very valuable
experience in that this the planning
inspector has given us
um
a great deal of information and
if you like a presumption in favor of
development of solar farms and he's put
it in the context of climate change of
responding to climate change the need
for renewable energies
and also is emphasized that temporary
nature of the installation and how the
the land is improved and within our
conditions already we have a land
Improvement I forget the words of it
management
policy
um
no anyway
he has at the end of his
um
decision got a list of um
Mitigation Of measures of mitigation
and comparing
that list with our own
um
list of conditions
it looks compatible and I'd like to see
those two things actually sort of
bonded together as it were so we've
taken advice on both levels not just
about the actual direction of travel
decision but also on the the measures of
mitigation we've heard from Mystic
cousins I think
philosophical point of view his attitude
towards farming is it
matches these these conditions he's
looking to the Future to a future
and and looking towards a sustainable
present if you like in order to ensure
that future happens
um
there are risk stuff through security I
think solar Farms is not the greatest
risk to our food security climate change
I think
must be top of that list
um farming is under a great deal of
pressure in this country
um
uh energy is one the costs of farming
I do know Farms which have been taken
out of food production completely in
order to sort of um enter into sort of
stewardship schemes work to increase
biodiversity
this is a kind of stewardship scheme in
that the land is being taken out of food
production in order to produce energy
some farming will be taking place which
again is is part of the conditions this
sort of
um on good management of grazing and
soil Improvement
um
so I I think I'm
in a very long-winded way and I
apologize I think we should approved
this application
um and move forward in that sense that
lessons have been learned
we we had a talk at the beginning about
not making this process political it has
become political uh it's not green party
policy to take land out of food
production in order to put solar cells
on bring party
policy is to put it on Brownfield sites
rooftops and new developments this is
not unfortunately government policy
we're not in government so we have to
work within the political framework that
is presented to us we have to make a
planning decision within the planning
framework so that's why I'm proposing to
accept
you're formally proposing that we accept
um the officer recommendation councilor
Harding
well if I could just add a comment to
this
which is that we have to determine every
planning application on its own merits
um
decision we take on this application
does not Prejudice what we decide on the
following two
I think one of the crucial aspects that
we need to consider in looking at these
is the amount of care and attention
which is going to be paid to genuinely
achieving a biodiversity net gain and to
accommodating as far as possible the
needs of the people who live locally and
I think when we come to look at some of
the other applications we might find
that there is a a distinction between
the way this application has been
approached by the applicants and the
other ones so just to say that um
the way we look at this one doesn't
necessarily determine the way we have to
look at the other ones
thank you
councilor hadingham
I mean I am still looking for a second
for Council of War boys
um thanks I am happy to second but be um
I'm just going to say like pretty much
everyone here we're sort of stuck
between a rock and a hard place but I do
feel that the the the landowner has
reassured us that that he's um he's he's
got his sights firmly set on the
environment and and the issue they have
Skylark mitigation and basically he's
wanting to do the best for the
environment which is obviously you know
you know in everyone's agenda here
and so yes I'm happy to Second it thank
you but councilor Mathison were you
going to say something else uh only only
very briefly that um
I think when when the chair spoke um
she she referred particularly to the the
appeal decision I think that and I think
the officers could perhaps just advise
me I think we we look when we looked in
June at the um Barrister's opinion in in
private
um that referenced a number of appeal
decisions
so we're not just depending upon the
um the the appeal decision that we did
not defend
we're actually looking at
you know in the in the the change from
then to now we're looking at a number of
appeal decisions that were made
subsequent I think possibly that the the
case officer did did say that uh earlier
on thank you councilor
um thanks I just wanted to say that I'm
sure um Roland said all right you know
whether he said it or not but we
absolutely want to listen to Branford
and berthal the the parish council that
say we need to hammer the conditions to
make sure they're all you know
absolutely nailed on and the rest sort
of thing
uh is that referring to the conditions
are you uh um yeah I I must admit maybe
we could just have a a sort of little
summary of of just to check that the
conditions that we've got on our
um officer recommendation do match
um or go beyond what the appeal decision
has said and what the extra ones are
just for a bit of clarity if we can do
that thank you yeah of course no problem
um just perhaps I answered councilman's
Point alongside that as well I think
they're
um the
term papers which is item 7c does also
cover this item to a degree you'll see
on page 29 there is the list of the
other appeal decisions
such a cross-reference but just to
confirm
yeah it should have said
yep yeah it's in something sorry yep so
that's uh yeah as and then just to go on
to the conditions yep so the conditions
in the appeal decision match those in
our recommendation to you with an
addition of a soil management condition
um following the earlier conversation in
I've just been having a look at what we
might be able to do we'd also suggest an
additional condition whereby the
applicant will be required to notify the
LPA us of the implementation of this
consent so we can be clear yes we're
implementing the Planning Commission or
we're not granting the appeal decision
because that would help our enforcement
colleagues immensely if they're
attempting to work out which one they
ought to be enforcing against in any
future arguments so give everybody
Clarity if they say upfront yes we're
imprinting this one we all know exactly
what's happened
and the council War boys you're happy
with that summary of the conditions
the officer thank you Joe and Council
hadingham
um so unless anyone else has got
anything to add
um I will now ask the um are we happy
that the airplane managers read out the
proposal or do we need to any more I
think we're fine so um I will now ask
the governance officer to conduct the
electronic vote thank you thank you
chair members that vote is now in
progress
councilor Penny would you like me to
take your vote verbally
oh okay I can take it verbally that's
fine
except thank you uh chair that's eight
votes for therefore that is carried
thank you uh thank you
um so that
um
uh that that application has now been
um approved uh now before we go on to
item 7B um I'm going to suggest that we
have a comfort Break
um 10 minutes till we can we come back
at quarter past 11
um so we can uh have a 10 minute break
uh welcome back uh we are now going to
move to item 7B DC 2202 667 Grange Farm
oldbury Road palgrave and I will invite
the case officer Jasmine wire to
introduce the application to the
committee uh thank you Jasmine
uh thank you members
um and uh thank you chair and good
morning
um so I'm presenting an application
today for the installation of ground
Mountain ground mounted solar PV and
structure at Grange Farm oldbury Road
Pearl Grove
so members are reminded that this
presentation does not replace the
content and detail contained within the
committee report
um some slight updates to the committee
report is that the applicant is now
submitted both a surface water drainage
plan and covering the sub the substation
and also an amended biodiversity net
gain assessment and these are with
Suffolk County Council floods and water
and police services ecology for review
so looking at the site now um here's an
aerial map showing the extent of the
site shown by the hatched area
and as you can see there are kind of two
distinct portions with Lion Road running
centrally between them and the site
covers 91.56 hectares
so putting the site into context there
are three kind of key roads that site
joins which are Millway Lane which is to
the north then you've got Lion Road
centrally and the a143 to the South
the site is wholly within the
countryside but policy CS2 of the course
strategy covers Countryside development
and is permissive of renewable energy
schemes
the village of palgrave is to the East
and I'll show you a later slide with the
the actual settlement boundary on
so in terms of constraints these are the
constraints covering the northern half
of the site and so the settlement
boundary of Powell Grove is shown
outlined in brown just to the east then
you've got several public rights of way
running near to under along the
boundaries of the site which are shown
by the kind of green dashed line and the
power grave Conservation Area starts
inside the settlement boundary where the
first kind of the list of buildings are
seen
yeah so just sort of here and again I'll
show you the exact boundary on the later
slide
then we've got the constraints to the
South
um so the site itself is not within any
sort of landscape or ecological
designated area and just to the
Southwest is the start of a special
landscape area just over here again
you've got some clustering of listed
buildings here here and here which again
there'll be a later slide on that and
you've got flood zones that run
literally just on that corner and site
just over there but besides that all
outside the site
of the 91.56 hectares 51.2 percent of
the land is grade 3A land which is
considered best and most versatile as
defined within National policy the
remaining 48.8 is grade 3B land which is
not best of most versatile land
food security issues have been noted
through the kind of numerous
representations and there is a section
within the committee report and
detailing this but food security and
agriculture in the UK is a very complex
picture and the impacts of a temporary
loss of agricultural land cannot really
be simplified to directly result in food
insecurity and I think that
one point to kind of
I suppose get to grips with in terms of
how that's that's framed within the best
and most versatile land
um so now looking at the the kind of
specific settlement boundaries so blue
outline shows where the certain boundary
for palgrave Falls
um at its nearest Point the proposed
sighting of the solar panels would be 40
meters from the settlement boundary in
most cases this is significantly further
but that would be kind of along this
point just here
oh
so in terms of Heritage assets now so
these are all of the Heritage assets
around the site and plotted on the map
so you've got a 31 grade two listed
buildings which are shown with the
orange then you've got one grade two
stylist to building which is shown by
the red and one grade one listed Church
um which show my green
the purple outline also then shows the
location of the powergrove Conservation
Area
um and at its closest point the site
lies at 260 meters west of that
Conservation Area
so then moving on to Heritage harm so
lifted from the map on the previous
slide these are the assets that the
Heritage team and historic income
consider would be affected by the
development
um the levels of harm identified are all
within the scope of less than
substantial there is no level of
substantial harm and albeit the the
levels of less and substantial is varied
across the different assets so Ivy
Cottage uh Long's Farmhouse and spring
Barn would have a very low level of
lesson substantial harm churches and
Peter is identified as having a very low
to low level Ivy House and the
powergrave conservation area would have
a low level and Valley Farmhouse would
have a low to medium level
um the reason Valley Farmhouse is is the
highest level of harm identified is
mostly owing to the location of the
substation which I will show you later
but just for reference that's where the
substation will be going
so in terms of the decent District
neighborhood plan this is an emerging
plan but it is given significant weight
based on the fact it's imminently going
to referendum the site does not fall
with any within any of the emerging
designations within that plan but the
two of the closest emerging designations
are the key view out of the village
which is shown by that blue and the
green Corridor to the South
so in terms of the site layout plan
um it's been amended since the
application was originally first
submitted to set the solar panels back
from some of the sensitive boundaries
which again when I come onto the
landscape and I'll explain more detail
and the proposal includes citing of
solar photovoltaic panels
um the installation of a substation and
other ancillary infrastructure including
inverter cabins and deer fencing
the soda farm would have an electrical
output of 48 megawatts and just a
correction to my committee report is
that the solofon would generate enough
energy to power in excess of 16 000
homes not eleven thousand
along the southern boundary of the
northern portion of the site there is a
20 meter buffer
just along here I don't know if you can
see it that well but there's kind of an
orange hatched area and that 20 meter
buffer area is proposed where the panels
would have a height of 2.5 meters as
opposed to three meters so there's a
slight reduction and then you've got a
30 meter setback distance as well from
the road
which again you'll see a little bit
clearer on some of the landscape plans
later on
um permissive paths and soft landscape
are also proposed and again we'll
discussed later
um in a later slide but one of the
permissive paths in this area runs from
here along this boundary and and then
across along this boundary here before
Crossing onto this side and going along
here
um access tracks are also proposed
within the site which are shown by kind
of those brown
lines and this is just the kind of
maintenance construction purposes
to the easternmost field within this
Southern portion so this bit over here
this would be initially these panels
would be initially cited on concrete
bases for archaeological reasons which
would then be removed post-determination
depending on what's found in terms of
the archeology
um the rest of the site again is
pretty much the same as what it is on
the Northern side there's a bit of a
setback
um distance just in this corner that I
forgot to mention earlier as well and
also there is a bit of a setback here
which again you'll see on the the
Landscaping plans and that's the
substation which is
slide
and so the substation would be adjacent
to an existing pylon in the Southeast
area of the site so there's an existing
pylon just here
and this is where the rest of the
substation would then fall
um so in terms of the how the substation
would actually look so there would be a
2.4 meter high Palisade fencing which is
different to the proposed fencing around
the rest of the site which I'll show you
again in a later Slide the compound will
measure approximately 77 meters in
length and the majority of the compound
would be no higher than about 6.5 meters
which is this sort of element around
here so the highest point is this bit
which is 6.5
um
the connection Mast would measure 28.9
meters but again it is no higher than
the existing pylon adjacent
the Landscaping plan over the years is
likely to obscure the majority of the
compounds albeit
obviously won't obscure the mast
um
so as the most potentially sort of
visible and sense development of The
Proposal obviously I noted earlier that
um Valley Farmhouse is kind of the
closest asset to this substation and the
applicants provided a Viewpoint showing
how the substation would actually look
within the site when viewed from the
public right-of-way and it's quite faint
but you can see the Mast just here and
this is where the actual compound would
be so this is from the public
right-of-way
um which again I'll show you on a later
slide
so the inverter cabins would sit amongst
the PV panels centrally within site and
be no taller than the actual PV panels
themselves so again it's very low level
development
so uh panels themselves as I've
mentioned would be three meters in high
the majority of the panels will be
installed via a driven mount system
within an area of the site and but
within an area of the site to the east
obviously as I mentioned where there are
archaeological uh there is
archaeological potential that will be
installed on a non-intrusive concrete
block
so in terms of the kind of security
measures so you've got um some CCTV
which again is no higher than the panels
uh then you've got the deer fencing
which surrounds most of the site and
some sort of access gates but the
defensing is
here and again uh it's two meters in
height so it's actually lower than where
the panels sit
um the CCTV would be on bases measuring
40 centimeters by 40 centimeters and
again as I mentioned will be three
meters in height
so in terms of the the kind of public
rights way and permissive paths within
the area and the public rights way is
shown by the green existing permissive
paths are shown in pink and the proposed
permissive path that's under this
application which would be secured by a
condition is show Orange
and along the north eastern edge of the
site and initially the public right away
is outside of the site so along this
area here this actually feels just
adjacent to outside of the site and then
it goes for within the site just on this
corner here
and then you've got a similar sort of
situation along here it's outside of the
site and then it falls within the site
just along here and they would remain
completely free from obstruction and
Suffolk County Council public rights way
team have confirmed they have no
objection to it
um and then in terms of the permissive
pass these are the areas which are to be
here and then kind of across
here to then link into the existing
path along here so it kind of rolls
around the entire site
so moving on to Landscaping now
so this is the whole Landscaping scheme
for the site and I will zoom in on on
later slides the Landscaping features
proposed include fencing permissive
paths native hedgerows native trees
Wildflower Meadow and gapping up
existing hedgerows
at the soft Landscaping will further
support increase biodiversity on the
site
then moving on so this is the northern
portion of the site
so look into the north of site the
panels are set back
the pan
El Way Lane
at the moment of 100 meters and a
minimum of seven meters in the areas
where it's only about seven meters new
hedgerows are posed so this is kind of
kind of a long
along this area here a lot of these
setback distances were discussed with
Play services Landscaping on the basis
of their kind of comments about
mitigating some of
Millway Lane is also a quiet Lane so
again this just increases the separation
distance of the panels to the existing
sort of landscape and again you'll see
this a little bit clearer on some of the
um site photos that I've got
and there's also a 30 meter setback
distance which mentioned earlier which
is along here which is to be planted
um and there'd then be that further 20
meters buffer just here where the panels
are lower
there's also an existing Central area
with an existing kind of pond which is
to be retained and undeveloped and
maintained for biodiversity purposes
um so in terms of the Southern
Landscaping plan again very very similar
in terms of the approach
um the sub um there's another setback
from the panels of the panels from the
southwest corner
over here which you can see so there's
again a kind of landscape buffer
um and any areas of the site where there
aren't already existing
um hedros and new hedros are to be
planted and where there are gaps it's to
be planted up
um
and then just zooming in on the
substation as I mentioned obviously the
the kind of most visible
potential area
so you've got existing planting along
this boundary and then there's new
proposed planting around that that Bunch
there and the Viewpoint was taken along
the public right-of-way which runs all
the way kind of up here so it's looking
that way where there currently isn't
Much landscaping and obviously this is
to be planted
this provides a kind of viewpoint of the
panels so we've got a couple of slides
like this similar to what was done with
the substation earlier
so this is actually where the panels
would fall and this is looking south
from Lion Road
but then we've got this is from Millway
Lane so again looking at this is where
the panels would be and initially this
is prior to the planting kind of
becoming established but then after that
planting becomes established
got a kind of Hedgerow which again
obscures the the view of that
in terms of access points there are four
access points would serve the site only
two of these which are the ones shown in
green just here and here would be for
construction purposes
so the other two would just solely be
for maintenance purposes which are shown
in blue and three access points are
along lime Road and you've got one along
the a143 notably there are no access
points at all along Millway Lane which
is that Quiet Lane
a transport statement and construction
management plan were submitted with the
application which shows that all
construction traffic will be rooted by
the a143 to avoid traveling through
Power Graves that will all come from
this direction and travel up
um
then just to show you the kind of access
points so these are both the
construction and maintenance access so
it's all of them
um they're all existing access points as
you can see obviously they are kind of
agricultural accesses at the minute they
are proposed to be upgraded and
obviously proportionate to their kind of
end use construction maintenance and
this is in line with the conditions
recommended by Suffolk County Council
highways
so in terms of cumulative impacts and
this was actually in one of the parish
council's comments to us and obviously
there is some concern locally about the
amount of sort of renewable energy and
energy type related projects coming
forward so Grange Farm is the
application site then you've got Marsh
Lane which is a another solar farm
um and then you've got the kind of
Norwich to Tilbury pylons
kind of running through the center there
um Marsh Lane soda Farm uh has currently
had an eia screening and scoping opinion
carried out on it but no formal planning
application has been made
um equally the the Norwich to Tilbury
line is progressing through consultation
stages and it is a nationally
significant infrastructure project
that's decided by the Secretary of State
and so given the kind of differing
levels of progress that all three of
these applications are all proposals
rather are at it's only Grange farm that
is currently a planning application to
be decided
and so under this current application
based on the lack of detailed
information we have about the other two
proposals it's not considered reasonable
to consider these projects in
accumulation with this solar farm in
terms of getting the applicant to
provide cumulative impact assessments at
this stage having said that and one of
the reasons that Marsh Lane has been
considered to be eia development is
based on the cumulative impact that
could arise so it's a kind of first pass
to the post type situation but this will
be considered
um later if that makes sense
so moving on to some site photos now and
the following slides will provide
different photos around different parts
of the site just to give you an idea of
the the kind of specific viewpoints a
lot of these are taken from the public
rights away and from the highway just so
you can see the kind of really visually
prominent things and things that people
locally will see
um so photo one is looking Southwest
through the site from the public right
of way along Mill Way Lane so it's right
at the northern part of the site
photo 2 is then again looking westwards
along Millway Lane there are a few gaps
in the Hedgerow along the the lane but
the majority of the Landers appear to be
enclosed by existing Landscaping in a
very similar manner to kind of what's
shown along here
and again this is where so this is from
uh looking into the site over here again
you can see there are existing hedgerows
around the kind of um
different areas of the site this is
probably one of the most open areas and
that's the one that was shown on that
Viewpoint earlier that the applicant
provided
we've then got some uh site photos from
lime road so these photos were taken
from the public or out of way running
along the Eastern edge of the site north
um of Line Road
so there's a pylon
um outside of adjacent to the site so
the site starts here then you've got the
public roadway here pylon and then
residential development here so you can
see the houses and the start of power
grow certain boundary Starts Here pylon
public right away sites over here
um
then again you can see that there are a
number of existing overhead power lines
and pylons running across the site in in
kind of various locations
um
so this is looking from the public right
of way right into the site again and
this is then looking across Lion Road
onto the southern side of Lion Road
and again this is where the panels would
be in this bit and that's just a zoomed
in version of there
and then finally on Berry Road looking
East and West along the a143 it's also
known in both directions as you can see
there are thick mature rows of of trees
and hedgerows obscuring a lot of the
views of the site and there are gaps but
again these are proposed to be planted
up as part of the application
so in terms of the overall plan and
balance this is a very brief summary of
the kind of harms and benefits of the
scheme and the full planning balance and
weight afforded to the harm as harms and
benefits of this game is set up within
the committee report
um a large proportion of the harms are
considered to be mitigated by condition
which are to the satisfaction of
consultees
there is some residual harm uh Heritage
harm
however again as noted earlier under
paragraph 202 of the mppf this harm has
to be weighed against public benefits
um which in this case those public
benefits are considered to outweigh that
harm
the recommendation is therefore to Grant
planning permission in the terms set out
in the committee report and subject to
that surface water drainage plan and
being satisfactory to Suffolk County
Council floods and water
thank you for listening
thank you
um so I now ask if any members have
questions and could I just remind
everybody to speak into the mic because
I think some people in the public area
are struggling to hear so maybe if you
could bring your mic a little bit closer
and speak into it um as clearly as you
can thank you Council having
thanks
um on slide 31 can you just show where
the existing pylons are you put the ones
in that are going to come from Norwich
children but can you just show with your
um your um pointy thing where where the
existing file online is
so you've got that pylon
um just over here just outside of that
site as well so again it runs kind of
through the site and it's quite
difficult to tell you where exactly some
of the pylons are but I think on one of
yeah
I'll be saying it's yeah it's it runs
across the site it's not obviously the
whole site and but there are there are
pylons on both parts of the fields right
thank you
any more questions councilor Mathison
thank you yeah the um I want you to
understand a bit more about the the kind
of technicalities of connecting these
solar Farms to the grid
um I mean the the I think one of the
um Brantford applications
um lays particularly emphasis on on
being within five kilometers of
something or other
um now this this application has got a
substation
um
but the the
one we've looked at already
didn't have a substation
so can you just help me to understand
what what is necessary or you know where
we're dealing with necessary proximity
or
you know I can't convenience let's put
it bluntly
um in you know where the you know are
they all being clustered in one place
because technically That's essential or
are they being clustered together
because it's it's handy
to do it like that yes so in terms of I
suppose taking it at a high level to
start with
um so obviously grid connection and grid
capacity is one of the the kind of
starting points and obviously the
further away that you are from a kind of
grid Connection in
I suppose group capacity
um you would have to obviously there
there is a kind of knock-on effect in
terms of how you would then be able to
connect in if you put it further away so
that's kind of a starting point
um in terms of the specific
technicalities it might be something
worth
um asking the applicant anyway but what
they because this was this was a
question that I've um I've already posed
to the outfit in terms of you know why
is it specific one kilometer distance in
terms of the search area
um so the distance varies on it on sort
of every project and depends on a lot of
factors uh affecting the project
economics including the cost of grid
connection unexpected yield from the
project
um which is in terms of you know that
capacity and obviously lots of uh
sort of strains
um the costs of grid infrastructure is
significantly more a higher grid
connection voltages uh such as 132
kilovolts which is the connection on
this project and there may be other
great costs to be taken into account as
well in this case the kind of viable
distance for a project of this size
given the capacity that they've got and
the grid connection rights that they've
got was one kilometers so that's how
they've how they come to it but as I say
it differs a lot between projects based
on the size the scale the capacity and
site constraints but
on the sort of technical elements you
might want to ask the applicant a little
bit more about that
any further questions if if not I'd like
to ask a couple of questions uh firstly
about the deer fencing uh because
clearly that is designed to stop deer
getting into the
um area but are there any like
permeability for smaller bits of
wildlife to get through that defense
that's my first question or is it
actually going to be a barrier to
everything other than a flying creature
and so obviously our ecology team have
reviewed
um all of the the kind of application
and the proposed landscape including
that dear fencing and there's no no
objection to it
um in terms of how the deer fencing
actually looks I don't know if uh let's
see if you could go back
so it is there are obviously as you can
see I don't know if that's
see my mouse there are gaps in it it's
not a complete it's not like a
close-boarded Tim fence
and obviously if there are some some
kind of concerns around that I'm sure we
can kind of take that away and and look
into it a little bit further if that's
something the needs
thank you my
given that the recommendation is to
allow the chief planning officer to
check on that um drainage or whatever it
was condition that may take a little bit
of time to get the consultation in and
in the meantime
our draft joint local plan may come back
from the inspector and therefore have
more weight so I'd just like you to
explain how our policy in the draft
joint local plan LP 25
is does that you know should our draft
local plan get slightly more weight
before the actual granting of planning
permission are we still okay with LP 25
um I think this is probably something so
at the minute
um as in my committee report the draft
local plan in the context of this scheme
we're saying has moderate way
um what I would say is obviously if
between us
um you know if
planning permission is granted subject
to obviously Chief planning officer
reviewing the surface or drainage plan
if something was to change I think we
would have to obviously review it and
it's it's likely that it could come back
to committee
um in terms of how it Accords with the
policy at the minute
there are some elements which we
probably need to look at a little bit
further in terms of the kind of
available sites obviously there is quite
a lot of information that's already been
submitted with this application
um and it's yeah that that's kind of all
we can really say at the minute without
having the examiners report back
thank you um does anyone else have any
further questions uh councilor
hardingham I'll take you first because
councilor mathison's already had a go
um first of all just the point of
information it does State somewhere in
here
20 hectares of the site SBN V land
um actually grade 3A is 51 so that comes
out at 46 sectors
so it's a
It's a larger area of BMV than uh do you
know whereabouts
um the commission report is something I
can paragraph 59.
14.9 or 14.9 over there okay
oh sorry
[Music]
it's a rather small point yes no I think
that probably is an error in terms of
the I can confirm 100 it is what is
noted in
[Applause]
pages
it's 1.2 so it definitely is 51.2
percent whatever that works out so yeah
apologies for that
um in terms of biodiversity Net game
um in the previous application that
we've just looked at
um they were claiming it was going to be
160 habitat Improvement
um just through the grass grazing and
the hedges that were going to be
um
established but this one appears to need
90 hectares of lowland Meadow
unless I've misread
and I think that might be for yeah so I
think there is there's kind of two
elements to it so there is some Skylight
mitigation which is required anyway
um the biodiversity net gain assessment
obviously was one of the the points to
play services ecology kind of raised um
a few questions with and that's why it's
recommended as a condition we have got
an amended biodiversity assessment that
gain assessment that's been submitted
now
um I'm not an ecologist so I would kind
of defer and wait for for that
consultation to come back before kind of
commenting on whether that's uh you know
a viable scheme
um but what I would say is obviously
biodiversity Net game doesn't actually
come in I think until November as a kind
of legal element
um obviously it's something that's been
considered now and there is undoubtedly
gonna going to be a Net game on the site
based on the fact it's intensively used
um for farming at the minute and
obviously there is going to be you know
hedgerows and lots of other elements but
yeah I don't think I could kind of
quantify at the minute
um yeah so but regardless of the
decision that we we take now I mean say
we were to approve
approve um the biodiversity net gain
element the conditions the plan is still
to be negotiated
yes yes so what I would say is we've got
um we have obviously got an amended
assessment that's been submitted in the
last couple of days we're Consulting
only at the minute
um but it's it would be either
conditioned if it's satisfactory to our
uh ecological Consultants
um we'd still condition that it's
obviously implemented but failing that
we'd put a condition on let's say you
know you need to submit a biodiversity
net gain assessment to us that's
satisfactory basically
thank you
I'll count the Mathison yeah the um
maybe getting confused between really
these at least these three different
solar farm applications at the weekend
um
this glints and glare issue that that
comes up
um now I think I've just finally found
what I was looking for partly so we've
got a condition there for interim
mitigation
um
I wondered what how that's done
um and I think what I can't find
probably because it's in in the third
one is
um
where it it's not
being offered
you know the the point being that you
need a hedge
and the Hedge isn't going to be there
for some years not to the height that's
required so what what are they proposing
to do
um or are we asking to be done by the um
the condition that's recommended uh on
this 821 of the papers yes so as a kind
of inter
there is uh the condition requires that
they provide a satisfactory means of
mitigation
um obviously if that can't be provided
then they they can't implement it until
it has been provided basically and what
I would say is obviously our
environmental health
um team are the ones that have assessed
this glint and glare assessment
obviously they've done this across
numerous solar farms and and again there
are a number of solar Farms across the
UK there is likely to be a mitigatory
measure and it's not that it's
unreasonable to say that there is a kind
of interim solution and it's just
obviously they need to need details of
that again it might be that the
applicant has some some further detail
on that
so so we
in terms of you know looking at the the
solar farms and we're going to be
looking at another one presently and
another one next month or the month
after and so on and so on
um so really we we want this to standard
condition effectively
um that we will always want that to be
provided if the hedges are not already
doing the job that's some extent one for
the area planning manager to make it
Noble yeah I think it is basically a
standard condition anyway obviously it's
dealt with on a kind of
um depending on whether there is an
existing hedge there or whether it needs
to be planted up and also the degree to
how close it is to sensitive receptors
so but it is yeah it is basically a
standard sort of thing that comes up on
solar Farms I think closest is not going
to be much of an issue really because
light travel is very very large distance
is very quickly
science
it's very fast uh uh councilor Elkin
um
do we know what size of hedge is going
to be planted because Hedges take quite
a long time to grow and would it be
reasonable to ask for the whips to be
you know if you put them in at this size
you're waiting five six seven years for
them to reach you know the head height
could we ask for them if we put in at
four or five feet for example I mean
it's it's completely possible for kind
of the Landscaping condition to be
stipulated a certain way and I'd need
check because obviously there was a lot
of information that was submitted with
this application including a landscape
and visual impact assessment as well as
landscape and plans and it's possible
that some of that information
is already provided and but it's
something we could we could certainly
make a note of and it's kind of a if
it's not already there we can we can
resolve it
thank you so that will give the
community a little bit quicker
protection from kind of visual intrusion
to hand up cancelable voice thank you
yes thank you
um yeah I think it's just looking
through the conditions and um
I think
um I've got a bit in favor of a bit of
cutting paste here where we could look
at the mitigations proposed by the
planet inspector for the previous
application could actually almost be put
in here because I'm looking for
soil
Improvement plan and I'm looking for
sort of whether grazing would be part of
the
ecological management plan and and it's
that kind of
detail I think that's needed because I
think
with the this this current butcher solar
farm applications it is the mitigation
of the effects of the modern landscape
biodiversity it's very crucial that we
actually get as good as good a deal as
possible for the environment
uh yes so the sewer management plan
and what things you know what the
general heading of the condition is
obviously if members are wanting to be
explicit about what that includes and
that's that's again absolutely fine I
suspect it probably is something that I
mean certainly in terms of the soil
management plan that condition I think
um Ron has already kind of gone into
detail on and it will be basically
universally kind of Applied condition in
terms of How It's worded
thank you any counselor holdingham
sorry
um following up on what councilor Elkins
was saying about hedgerows in the first
place
um my experience and understanding is
that putting a bigger plant in doesn't
necessarily give you a bigger hedge in
five years time in in fact smaller
plants um
will generally establish better and grow
away quicker but um
um it seems to me that getting these
hedgerows and the planting established
and actually growing vigorously
quickly is the crucial thing in terms of
mitigating the harm to local communities
to what extent can we can we condition
the management plan for the for the
hedging to make sure that it does
actually establish and grow away that if
we get unfavorable weather
um it's looked after properly there's
adequate mulching
um
and ultimately the tree guards are
removed at the end of their useful life
and in terms of density of Hedges which
is crucial for the Wildlife benefit that
they get the wider the hedges
increases the
the wildlife benefit enormously can we
specify the number of rows of hedging
plants that go into head to make up a
hedge yes so it tends to be this kind of
two Port well two or three points to
their kind of landscaping set of
conditions is kind of standard so we
could have one that essentially covers
you know submitting to us the the levels
the quantum the kind of
um species everything that kind of as an
outline of this is what we will be doing
then it kind of comes down to when they
do it so we can you know request
Advanced planting that's certainly
something that's possible
um equally in terms of the management
there's a landscape in ecological
management plan
again that has to be submitted to us
satisfactory with consultation with
landscaping and
our ecologists as well
um in terms of making sure that it
doesn't then I mean there normally is a
part in the condition that does say if
it's um
dyes or it's diseased it's replaced
um so it will just be a case of we can
have that information submitted To Us by
condition we can obviously discharge it
subject to it being satisfactory and and
it will just be a case of making sure
that it's monitored
um
again that's that's kind of I think that
probably covers all of the kind of
standard conditions that we can use I
don't know if you've got any other no I
was literally just gonna say and they're
in the recommendation at the minute but
I have um you know we could definitely
mention that advanced Hydro planting if
that's where members are minded to go to
um
did I see I I did see your hand up
Council Madison but I don't think
councilor Pelley has asked a question
yet so I'm gonna I'm gonna hand over to
councilor Penny and then I'll come back
to you councilman
yeah I was just going to add on to the
points about hedging and would it be
possible to specify that um
aspects such as heading as hedging were
commenced before construction began at
an appropriate time of year
uh yes so that's essentially what
Advanced planting would be
um so yeah we can we can kind of kind of
specify
um obviously it has to still be
reasonable I think what I think case
considering the kind of visual impacts
it might be I'm just trying to say that
there's there's no point planting a
hedge in the middle of the summer for
example and then famous yes so the
standard wording of our conditions does
specify that it kind of has to be
planted in an appropriate planting
season obviously don't put it in when it
it's not going to actually work
councilor Mathison yeah thank you yeah I
I
I was going to leave this until we get
if we got you know get to the end and
talk about conditions and so on but but
the
you know we're seeing more and more
cases of where the Landscaping fails
significantly and
um you know we're getting a drought
of 28 days yeah can we you know can we
have a look
really at the detail I mean
councilor hardingham we're exploring the
question already
carefully
um
that we
you know the the quality of the
maintenance
has to be improved because you know if
if the condition says Replacements
within the first five years and and then
there's a you get a replacement a lot of
little tweaks to put in the following
planting season and you know we've lost
a year
um you know there's no penalty well
there's a bit of a penalty and they have
to do it again but there isn't you know
we're losing the the the the the benefit
for a year
I mean not too about the glints and
Glenn now which is talking about the
wider biodiversity gains
um you know can we do more in the detail
of what we write
about these things please
I think in in terms of the conditions
they are already quite
um comprehensively worded in terms of
the level of information that we require
when they come in to discharge those
conditions and obviously in terms of the
maintenance and management plan that's
the reason that that's put on there on
some smaller scale developments you
don't actually put management plans on
but obviously for a scheme of this size
it's important that you have a
maintenance and management plan and it's
possible and I think a lot of them do
tend to have kind of periodic review
sort of mechanisms built into them as
well
um again that that detail is something
that will be assessed by our landscape
and ecology Consultants as well so
and that's you know they're the ones
that we will be looking to to kind of
make sure that that's established
obviously if the for whatever reason the
Landscaping plan wasn't implemented
properly that would then be a kind of
issue to fall within uh with enforcement
uh thank you any any more Council of War
boys
uh yeah could
sound a little bit more clarification
please on on the fencing and CC TV
cameras I I'm assuming the CCT cameras
World tab lights
connected and they'd only be on the
substation they wouldn't be on the
perimeter
so I Believe on on the um on the side of
our planet is shame that the CCTV is
mostly for the substation and I don't
think there was any other CCTV but again
it might just be something that the
applicant knows
before I can kind of find the answer and
in terms of the the kind of lighting I
think there was already a condition
um in terms of external yeah temporary
external lighting details to be
submitted and permanent lighting is to
be restricted and so again that comes
into the whole kind of restriction on
lighting
um and in terms of the fencing obviously
as I mentioned there are two different
types of fencing so you've got a
slightly more secure fence around the
substation for obvious reasons
and then you've got a deer fence that
goes around the the rest of the site
so the
the cameras around the substation could
have lights which came on
uh
I would need to check whether we've got
anything on that
um in terms of we are conditioning that
there is an
um well in terms of the kind of
temporary levels of lighting for
construction purposes obviously that's
that's to be conditioned for that to be
submitted to us and then there will be a
restriction on other external lighting
it might be that there is some lighting
required for security purposes around
the substation but again that can kind
of be covered by the condition
I think so because we could have cameras
which don't need any external light
yeah it's
as I say I don't know the details on on
what CCTV cameras will be installed they
are going to be low level cameras
because it's they're only three meters
high
so they're they're no higher than
the the solar panels themselves as I say
I think it would be worth probably
asking the applicant to clarify some
further information on that
thank you uh cattle Lawrence
I'm just a little bit concerned that we
seem to be
um placing quite a lot of emphasis on
salt management plans and relying on
claims by the applicants of soil
enhancement by grazing and um in fact
and yet in our supplement agenda
supplement on page 33 from Care Suffolk
claim their claims have improved soil
quality of solar Farms are unstamped
unsubstantiated by scientific evidence
and they go on to say regards to
long-term impact of solar way on soil
quality
there could be disbenefit to the soil
resource due to undowns as a result of
Solar Development infrastructure is
unclear to what impact the solar panels
may have on soar properties such as
carbon storage structure and
biodiversity
I'm getting a little bit concerned that
each of these applications now we're
asking for soil management plans
um how how those plans relate the issues
when it doesn't seem here to be evidence
that there is Improvement in the soil
quality by creating such structures
and so obviously the the kind of
representation that you refer to wasn't
directly in relation to this application
obviously I know the the kind of broader
relevance of it and
during the uh the inquiry that was into
the first application that you well the
resubmission of the first application
that you've just heard and witness
evidence was considered to be by the
planning inspector and that's where it's
you know considered under
cross-examination and was considered to
be persuasive and obviously there there
has to be some element of scientific
evidence in terms of how that witness
even was allowed to provide that
evidence and
examination so they have got to have
some professional credentials as to how
they've ended up speaking on that matter
and the soil management plan obviously
in terms of
how we we can word it however it is kind
of you know members consider that the
specific points we can we can really
tease those out through the management
plan if it's that they you know want I
suppose review mechanisms again that's
something that you know we can look into
um but I think what I would say is there
is also no evidence to suggest that they
are damaging so it's it's kind of uh I
suppose a double-edged sword really on
that on that
thank you
um
uh looks like we have no further
questions of the officer so I will now
invite the public speakers to address
the committee and first of all we have
from palgrave Parish Council Neil Weston
who is going to join us for the teams
link so uh um hope you can hear us now
see you
yes I can hear you
hear you uh so if you would like to
begin and I will time you with a three
minute timer thank you
okay first of all my apologies for not
being there this came up at a time when
I had a family holiday plan so I do
apologize also General comment I mean if
film the comments I've heard so far I
just wonder if this application is um
ready for um uh uh consideration but um
but they're just general points I'll now
um talk to the specifics here just one
minute
by now you will all be too aware of the
power of residents and their elected
representatives objections to this Solar
Development it runs deep and damages
people myself included our skill sales
is a green LED council is it right that
the vast majority of local residents
should be ignored is it right the
neighborhood plan should be ignored is
it right that the Suffolk County council
member for palgrave should be ignored
and is it right that our local MP who
represents powergrade in Parliament
should be ignored on this planning
application
should it be acceptable for a solar farm
twice the size of powergrade yes twice
the size of powergrade be built
literally within touching distance of
the village yes just a few meters away
that 140 Acres of heavily irrigated BMV
Farmland be covered with solar panels
when vast amounts of offshore wind
energy and nuclear power will be coming
on stream shortly
should it be acceptable that slave
enforced labor be used to produce these
Chinese silicon panels that are shipped
to Suffolk with not a great Prospect of
reuse or recycling
shouldn't you refuse a development that
harms our red listed skylarks our
protected Great Crested newts and
countless other large species
shouldn't you refuse a development that
causes significant harm to Residents
mental health and substantial harm to
valuable Heritage assets
shouldn't you as a Green Day Council
persuade the developer to think again
and propose something in better and more
considerate to the environment than the
residents of palgrave
ask yourselves these questions before
you vote on this proposal we as
residents for small but beautiful
Suffolk Village can only trust that you
will help us and make the developer and
landowner think more about the community
that must live with these things and
less about the profit that they are
going to make over the half a lifetime
that these panels will be there
thank you for listening to this plea on
behalf of the residents of palgrave
represented by their Parish Council
uh thank you if you'd just like to hang
on in case there are any questions of
the parish council any members got any
questions counselor Elkin
hello thanks for speaking to us I just
wondered if there had been if you could
describe what consultation had taken
place between the parish council and the
community and the the developer of this
site
we we had a village meeting uh regarding
the fairly early stages to see what the
general
um census was for this and it was
overwhelmingly against there was only I
think one uh one supporter and the
landowner who supported it so in terms
of consultation with the community
there's been
um obviously it's been going on for a
long time there's been extensive we've
also had a number of submissions a
number of First submissions from the
parish council that have been made and
discussed in open Forum where members of
the public have been president at Parish
Council meetings there has been little
if any I think really just zero
engagement with the developer they made
a tiny change early on with regards to
some small setback on Millway Lane but
there's been absolutely nothing the
development the original proposal is uh
left as it was there are a whole bunch
of areas of the development which don't
have edging it's not absolutely clear
from there but Millway Lane there's a
lot of the
boundary that hasn't got any hedging
involved basically there's been very
very very low levels of Engagement they
haven't been interested in talking to
the community
thank you any further questions of Mr
Western
thank you very much
um so I I'd now like to call on an
objector Jeremy Moynihan who's also
joining us for our teams
um so uh Jeremy if you'd like to
um just check you can hear us and we can
see you yeah we can hear you thank you
very much so if you would like to let us
know your representation and I will time
you for the three minutes thank you
thank you so my name is Jeremy Moynihan
my wife and I live at the Guild Hall in
belgrave and I wish to speak on behalf
of a number of objectives to the Grange
Farm solar application and to
consideration today
this is a massive Solar Development
right next to our village it covers 220
Acres which is more than double the size
of palgrave as Neil has said the
developer has not reduced the size or
tried to move the boundary to easy
impact on palgrave is literally meters
from the Bilter barrier in battle Grove
52 of the development will cover BMV 3A
bombland with the remaining 48 being 3B
the landowner has been the recipient of
significant Central grants over the
years to provide irrigation for this
farmland
so its value for food production has
been massively enhanced at our cost
the ecological impact of the development
will be huge it will destroy a Skylark
breeding ground with the only mitigation
put forward by the developer is the
spurious suggestion that they will be
relocated
the habitat of other species will be
destroyed ponds containing Great Crested
newts will be isolated and Disturbed
large herds of deer and brown hairs
displaced due to miles of continuous
fencing surrounding the entire site
this is in effect an eviction notice to
the wildlife that many villagers enjoy
seeing and my wife loves to photograph
the passing quietly into the west of
palgrave will be abandoned by residents
due to the unsightly views that will
replace the Glorious ones that are
currently seen these past and byways
from the village preserve residents
mental health during the covet pandemic
and the impact on residential immunity
will be huge
views to the west of the village will
consist of nothing but a sea of silicon
panels protected views identified in the
neighborhood plan will be severely
compromised by the development what is
the point in protecting these views when
the First Development proposal writes
roughshod over them
this massive development will come right
to the edge of palgrave and cause
substantial harm to the listed Valley
Farmhouse the delightful pilgrave
Conservation Area and the grade one
listed Church along with other listed
assets
the development should be refused on
amenity ecological and Heritage grounds
and especially for the destruction of
BMV Farmland which will result
according to Dr Sandra Knapp of the
Natural History Museum
the best thing that came out of the
Glasgow climate change Summit was a
recognition and articulation of the fact
that we cannot solve the climate change
crisis unless we also address our
biodiversity loss both of these things
together are two intrinsically linked to
try to deal with them separately the
thing that really drives biodiversity
loss is land use change and that is in
part driven by climate change it is a
vicious circle
we all understand the need to Source
renewable energy and stop the use of
fossil fuels and we don't object to
solar in this respect however given that
we currently cannot provide enough food
for our population and rely to a huge
degree on imported foodstuffs
sacrificing good growing land to solar
can only make this problem worse so we
implore you to look at the wider picture
and not support this ill-conceived
industrialization of the countryside but
instead supports solar farms and panels
where they belong on roofs and
Brownfield sites
and I just like to finish by saying Neil
I completely Echo uh what you said if
you look at this application the number
of questions that are still unanswered I
just don't see how you can possibly
recommend approval thank you very much
for your time thank you again if you'd
just like to hang on in case there are
any questions does anyone have any
any of Mr Monahan
um I would like to ask in in terms of
negotiation with developer how should
the community come up with
mitigation measures or confessions that
the developer might make in order to
make the The Proposal more acceptable to
the community and and what would those
be it would be very interesting to
commit you to know you know in what way
the impact on the community could be
softened as it were or all I could say
counselor is that we we um in the
objections there were a number of
suggestions and to be perfectly Frank
the the consultation process was pretty
much ignored by the Developers
did you want to come back
yes please um could you give me an
example or two of of suggestions that
were made that would make the whole
marvelous painful to the community
sorry Neil can you help out with that
one by any chance
yes um if Mr Weston can answer that
that's that's okay
yes yes I'm perfectly happy to talk
about a couple of points I think the
um the closeness to the village is uh uh
crazy uh I think they even there were
some suggestions about squaring up uh
the diagonal element of it and moving
away further away from the village I
think that is essential from our point
of view I think also the fact that it
comes so close to Millway Lane Millway
Lane is a absolutely gorgeous uh Quiet
Lane it's used intensively for dog
walking and horse riding and all of
those recreational Pursuits that we who
live in a country love I think the
setback there should be massively
improved there is a fantastic tree line
going East-West that the solar panels
could be hidden behind there's an
existing tree line just meters away from
where they're going to be installing the
panels
um that tree line should be utilized to
hike
um yes it makes it smaller but you know
I I think ultimately there's been no
consideration of the community in any
respect or any aspect of it at all
um it's been terrible so I think it
much increased setbacks on Mill Way Lane
because you will notice I think if uh if
you see the map again there's a
community a very small community just a
hamlet of three or four houses uh a
Miller way Farm that's surrounded on
three sites by solar panels I mean I
just think it's completely unacceptable
that the developer who has a choice not
to do this has chosen to do it so I
think setbacks I think from the village
to the west of palgrave so that it
doesn't come within a set distance of
palgrave say 150 meters of Belgrade I
think further setbacks from the road and
setbacks from Millway Lane uh to the
existing uh hedge line which is a very
well established hedge line then some
level of acceptability would be would be
given to the residents of palgrave but
where it is at the moment the mass
they've taken the massive uh the the the
highest level of intrusion they could
possibly do as close to the Village I
think frankly if you approve this
development it would be very difficult
to refuse any developments
thank you
uh any further questions
uh thank you uh to both Mr Moynihan and
Mr Weston
um thank you very much uh uh we don't
have a supporter
uh we do have the agent Rob Shaw
um if you'd like to uh uh speak now uh
thank you very much
good afternoon uh Rob Shaw I represent
uh Pathfinder clean energy we're a
British based Renewable Energy company
and our vision is to help the country
avoid the worst effects of the climate
emergency and to reduce our dependence
on fossil fuels our additional priority
here is to reverse the loss of
biodiversity in the local area
the climate emergency is now affecting
all of us and the cost of living crisis
means that many families will need to
choose between heating or eating
solar energy helpfully is now one of the
cheapest sources of power
our solar farm will generate clean
renewable energy for over 16 000 homes
the beauty of our solar farm is that
farming will continue the farmers are
here with us today and we'll continue
alongside solar generation while taking
the land out of the damaging cycle of
intensive agriculture
research shows that the biggest threat
to food security is actually climate
change
the farmer's experience here is that the
land is actually quite poor yielding and
requires very significant chemical
fertilizers so leaving it fallow for the
40 years will help to improve its
quality by the time the soil the the
solar farm is removed
we have actually engaged very
extensively with the community and I'm
happy to elaborate on that and actually
I think their their feedback has
improved the scheme that's before you
today
we've taken an extensive we've
undertaken extensive work to identify
this as an appropriate site following
consultation we would remove the
development over 100 meters away from
Millway Lane and added those 30 meter
buffers either side of of Line Road
we've included nearly 1.5 kilometers of
new hedgerows and improved unproposed
new permissive footpaths
we've added mammal gates in answer to
the question to allow permeability and
we've in principle agreed a community
benefit fund of of over 360
000 pounds
we used existing mature trees to screen
the substation and we've worked with the
landowners the farmers to create
habitats for wildlife to breed and to
forage
and will and a management plan will then
ensure that that those are protected and
maintained along with the hedgerows
and we've designed the scheme to ensure
there will be no noise impact
so in summary our site is not within a
designated landscape and the scheme is
well contained
despite its size
we cannot address the climate emergency
by relying on rooftops and solar alone
and we must decarbonize not just homes
but
and transportation as as well
so I would along with 130 biodiversity
net gain that we are able to present we
think this is a fantastic scheme and
we'd encourage you to go with your
officer's recommendation and approve
this scheme thank you
thank you
um do we have any questions of Mrs Shaw
Council or Mathison was that your hand
popping up there
note
um and
um yeah I was encouraged to hear I think
I heard you say that that you were
offering Community benefits to the tune
of 350
000.
um yeah I I was intended to ask you
if you would be doing that which is good
to hear that you are
um what I was wondering about
particularly is whether we could um I
mean we could possibly consider this as
conditions if we are minded to approve
um in terms of providing
um electric vehicle charging insulation
um at the Village Hall
um and and perhaps to pay for some of
the electricity
um for for that
um you know details of that'll be
working out I realized and
um
yeah that's so yeah that's the yes sorry
that is that is the question yeah how do
you feel about that
would you would you like me to respond
is that acceptable yeah please respond
so
we
during the we met with the the Parish
Council on on several occasions
including at the public event uh and
discuss various options for Community
benefit one of those the outcomes of
that was the the permissive paths that
you've seen through through the solar
farm
um
one of the suggestions that we had made
and others certainly raised was whether
there was opportunities to put electric
vehicle charging points in I think we'd
be very open to to ironing out those
sort of details within that that sort of
pop that we provisionally agreed whether
we provide that or whether the community
uses the money to provide it we're very
open to continuing that dialogue
thank you if I can just um follow on
from that because I too was going to ask
about the community benefit fund
um can you just clarify that the
permissive paths are not included in
that 350k or are they also included in
that 350k
um and and would you be
um uh receptive to have some sort of
community liaison group with the
community
um so that they get what they want out
of that money rather than what we impose
on them or or you impose on them
um because it should be really them who
decide
um what benefits they they feel that
they would like
yeah I think I think that's absolutely
right so there's a few things to say so
the Community Fund is about 360 overall
it amounts to about nine thousand pounds
per year
um
the permissive pattern not included in
that that will be something that will be
created as part and managed as part of
the the solar farm itself
uh during uh the the meetings we had uh
pre-application there was certainly a
suggestion uh I believe from the Parish
Clerk that we set up some form of
community liaison I I don't see any
problem that we welcome did at the time
we'd be very happy to to do so it makes
a lot of sense we're going to be there
for 40 years we want to be a good
neighbor we want everyone to to be able
to have a means to work things out not
just through construction but long term
thank you uh councilor Elkin
thank you I had
I had we had a one kilometer search area
I think
um and we've we've had other
applications in front of us which looked
over a five kilometer
site so there was some technical
explanation earlier but I just obviously
this is a massive solar farm next to a
very small village so it'd be great to
hear
how this particular site was chosen
um do you want me to give my second
question or would you rather
if you don't mind I'll answer that one
because uh otherwise I'll get the second
question will fall out of my head so
um the as as as Jasmine suggested you
know at the the distance away from from
a point of connection varies depending
on on the site specific so we've we've
got another site that's got a five
kilometer radius in this case we chose a
kilometer either side of the line it's
not a radius around a point this is a
very extensive line uh through uh that
part of uh this part of Suffolk there is
uh all of this is is was submitted with
our site search document but we we take
a very methodological sequential
approach to identifying sites once we've
identified a location a a capacity on
the grid connection because without that
we've got nothing we then start to look
at the economics and we start to look
sequentially at agricultural land grades
we've avoided grade one I don't think
there is any grade one in this part of
the world but there's plenty of grade
two we've avoided that and as far as
possible we've tried to to to avoid uh
as much best in most versatile as we can
clearly we want to avoid uh uh things
like landscape designation so we're not
in a in a valued landscape here we're
avoiding Heritage ecological designation
so we sequentially knock out sites and
ultimately uh we weigh that against
whether we've got a willing landowner so
put all those together this was a site
that we were able to bring forward and
is deliverable
before before you go on
um I understand that Mr Weston's got his
hand up on teams I'm sorry Mr Weston uh
it's not appropriate for you to join in
the questioning here
um so if I'd like to just go back to
counselor
thank you
um my other question was why this size
um we had a pretty passionate plea from
representatives of the parish you know
they're saying they're not anti-solar
they understand why we need Renewables
but does it have to be so huge does it
have to come within 40 meters of the
village you know could you square up a
field so you know I don't know how many
paddles you'd lose by doing that
um could it be a little bit smaller and
still be economically viable that would
reduce the impact on on all of them who
have to sort of live with this for the
next 40 years so yeah why this size
yeah and it's it's a it's a it's a
reasonable question to ask and it's one
that you know we ask ourselves when
we're developing laying these sites out
our our land ownership comes right up to
palgrave
what we're trying to avoid is is you
know uh uh a
a a a zoomed down look a plan view only
and using that as the basis for well
let's move it back further here our
approach is to to look from the ground
uh where the most sensitive points are
so where we've come closer to to
palgrave just north of Line Road it's
because there's quite extensive mature
screening between them and the houses
which has allowed us to closer to the
South though of Lion Road where you've
got the set the setback that sort of
triangular piece uh that's it's open at
the moment we wanted to set it further
back with some so set it a bit right so
that it basically comes up to where the
pylons are so the the existing overhead
pylons form the the boundary and we
tested that extensively through photo
montages through site visits through
assessment
s determined that actually you know we
could Clump this close to to palgrave
but during the consultation period
legitimate concerns some of those raised
by by the the two speakers which led us
to to set the development 30 meters back
either side of Line Road it's an entry
into the the the town and therefore you
know we felt it would be good to set
that back
so so we've used the kind of on the
ground approach to determine is this the
the right sort of scale for this
location but ultimately you know we are
as a nation we've got to decarbonize so
we've got capacity for a 48 megawatt so
export here that determined our ideal
size
if we could possibly do it
okay
any did I see Council Lawrence and
followed by Council of War boys
a couple of questions if I may did I
hear you wait to say that this community
level is actually nine thousand pound
per year
so by 30 years time when it's worthless
with insulation and everything else
so yeah so it's a it's an inflation
linked
contribution so it'll be nine thousand
year pounds per year for the full
duration of the 40 years but index Lent
okay thank you
the other point is we heard from the
speakers that they might consider or
maybe it'd be more possible if there was
a 150 meter Gap that between the village
and the solar cells solar panels oh are
you open to that
negotiation
so
as sort of referring back to my my
previous response rather than just
taking a sort of blunt right let's set
it back a certain distance we took a lot
of care to determine which were they
which views and which uh edges were most
sensitive we our view if you look and if
you if you went down there once it's
built you would see very little uh as on
those points where you're closest to to
power
where we've already set it back a
substantial distance that's because
there is little screening at the moment
so we felt it was sensible to move it
back
we we we
engage very positively from the outset
and throughout and try to address as
many as the of the the comments that
have been made by palgrave and others uh
within the commercial realities of a
scheme you know this has to to
financially make sense or or there is no
scheme we think we've we've made some
very considerable concessions
uh councilor War boys
uh yes thank you chair uh yes too brief
questions
um the first one is about security
cameras and uh
we've always mentioned sort of
restrictions and having permanent
lighting but are these cameras going to
trigger lights or are you going to have
lights with them because there's going
to be animals floating walking about
which may well trigger off security
lamps as well
um the second question is about the the
nature of the day offense in itself is
it absolutely necessary it's it's
continuous can it be more permeable
um
so
there is no lighting permanent Lighting
on the site so the security cameras will
not have lighting that so they are
AI they are thermal so there won't be
any lighting there is I believe some we
would have some lighting on the
substation for emergency uses only so
this isn't something that's just going
to come on through a uh through a sensor
so as Jasmine noted in in her
presentation uh if there is to be
lighting we would need to agree that in
advance but as things land stand
the CCTV is designed to capture images
from within the development not outside
so they are pointed inwards and they're
a standard feature of any solar farm
on your second question about the deer
fencing so we have included and this was
one of the early suggestions I think
from from uh the community we have
included
what I call them mammal Gates they're
kind of badger Gates they're designed to
allow uh larger mammals
to to pass through unimpeded and this
and the smaller ones you know this is
standard fencing within that you get
within the uh in the agriculture
thank you thank you
um any further questions
uh thank you very much Mr Shaw
um now um the ward member unfortunately
is
um
unable to be here
no no but we've got the written you've
got a written thing that you've printed
for me
um so
um uh the board member is councilor
Weller who was hoping to be able to get
here but he hasn't he has sent us a
written representation which
um I think
um have you got a printed copy or do I
need to find it on my screen
um
maybe if you can find it faster than me
uh
I I found um the uh a
representation from councilor Weller
um so uh
if I can just read that out I'd like to
thank officers for their time and effort
in preparing this sensitive and
contentious proposal to committee
whilst personally favoring sustainable
energy production having listened to the
volume and range of objections of the
body of palgrave residents I make two
specific observations in support of
those objections generally firstly the
cumulative effect it is perverse at
section 717 to state that insufficient
information is known to the planning
Authority regarding a proposed adjacent
solar farm when comprehensive details of
that project have been publicly
consulted upon by the developer
for pearlgrave residents at least the
cumulative impact of multiple solar
developments have been placed
conspicuously before them The Wider
effect of multiple developments
magnifies existing material objections
for wildlife biodiversity and visual
impact
secondly broader ethical objections
relating to Modern slavery and forced
labor the universities of Sheffield
Hallam and Nottingham among others have
published contemporary research setting
out evidence of human rights
contraventions in the mining of raw
materials used in the manufacture of
solar panels a local Authority in all
matters excluding its function as a
planning Authority
must have regard not only to its own
ethical conduct but to that of its
commissioned suppliers and contractors
it is regrettably observed that
government has not made provision for
ethical moral material considerations in
determining planning applications
my initial concerns regarding mitigation
for skylarks in this application
application have been addressed by the
enso appeal decision I would ask the
committee to consider specifically that
mitigation of alternative nesting
locations is conditioned for the
lifetime of the solar farm if it is
minded to adopt the officer's
recommendation to Grant approval
um and I I think he apologizes for not
being able to be here in person so that
was the comments from the Ward member so
I'd now like to open this up for debate
councilman
it's comfortable break before we start
um
if we must but two minutes
uh thank you um for that short break
um so I'd now like to open this item Up
For Debate as to anyone who would like
to uh
start
councilor Lawrence thank you
my observation is that to have 220 Acres
of fenced land so close to the proximity
of programs will be uphold and I
wouldn't want to live there the first
thing I do I put my place up for sale
but probably nobody would buy it
cue anyone
anyone or if nobody else is going to say
anything I think this is a incredibly
difficult decision to make actually
because I completely understand the um
concerns of the residents of powergrave
and I'm I'm still a little bit at a loss
as to why that that corner that sort of
um easternmost protrusion of the sites
does come so close to the the built up
area of power grave I've just actually
taken a look at Google Street View
um along that road and the applicant
talked about oh some natural screening
well it's just the corner of a field
there's nothing in the field so you know
couldn't we just move that back another
40 meters
um okay let's have a compromise the the
villagers wanted 150 meters and you've
got 40 meters so come and come join in
the middle and make it about 80 or
something so it's not quite so
um close
um but it is extremely difficult
um decision for us to make because
um there is this you know uh pulling do
we want the land for food production do
we want the land for energy production
um having all that fencing does make it
look a little bit industrial
um but we have heard in our other cases
about
biodiversity net gain
um because having a a solar farm with
with um hedging and grass is actually
more biodiverse than a than a great
field of of arable crop
um you know and we've heard I think
we're reassured that the fencing will
allow
um most of our mammals to get through
um but not the Deer
um
and I think I think we in this nation
have a strange
um relationship with deer on the one
hand we want to preserve it and then
they kill them
um and it was Park anyway
um you know you're not allowed to hit
him on the road but let's go and shoot
them later
um I'm not quite sure quite where deers
to sit in our biodiverse um food
um you know
natural environment
um so I I'm very torn on this
development because it is it is just so
so very big
um and and
you know
couldn't they have just pulled it back a
little bit further from the village it
wouldn't have made that much difference
to the number of solar panels
um but anyway I'll I'll listen to what
others have got to say
um uh but I think I think we're going to
be very torn
um on this decision thank you uh
councilor math
wasting a lot of words and echoing what
the chairs already said
um yes it is difficult one of the things
I wondered about in terms of mitigation
and of the food issue and also
maximizing the the
um Improvement of the soil
um can we actually condition requiring
grazing
to take place
um
or is that something that's beyond our
remit
is that something that well either of
you can comment on uh at the minute I
don't think there is anything we can do
condition wise because say
hypothetically if the solar farm wasn't
even coming forward it all land
basically starts off as agricultural
land so there is absolutely no
requirement for anyone to do anything on
that bit of land farming could seize
tomorrow and it's possible that we could
maybe put a condition on that related to
a scheme of kind of what they plan to do
to be submitted to us but again I don't
think there is any way we could kind of
say you have to
do well have Livestock on I don't see
how we can enforce or even if that's
reasonable no it's a difficult one I
mean we could include something in the
soil management plan that the soil
management plan could include measures
such as grazing to encourage it but I
think you're right I don't think there's
a way we could require it to happen
if I could come back on that jet I've
got I've got my note here's says that
the in the the appeal page 105 105
your pill oh well perhaps that is yes
yes but paragraph 415
um talks to summarizes the appeal
um and um the inspector there seems to
be suggesting that that
um the grazing can be secured by
planning condition
that was it that was in the interest of
Soul quality rather than actually
producing some some lamb or mutton but
um nevertheless
um
that's I think that's what I was
depending
um well I think in terms of that
specific appeal decision it's not that
we are um
moving a condition or rather inspector
included a condition that required
grazing it was more wrapped up in the
benefits of that soil management
um so obviously if they're saying there
is a soil you know benefit I suppose and
we're doing all these things in order to
do it
fine I think it comes down to the whole
we just can't require someone to graze
on that bit of land it's like saying to
a farmer somewhere
um on any bit of land you have to farm
it with we have no control over that
uh thank you
um councilor hardingham I think you had
your hand up
um I'm very struck by this
um difference between the um
what the applicant and the objectives
are saying about the level of
negotiation
the agent is saying that that they've
negotiated and taken into account what
the parish has said but I think we'll
really take notice of What the residents
feel about it and it seems to me that
there ought to be room for much more
uh
uh a much more conciliatory approach
from the from the company and the
applicant um to satisfying what the
parish and the residents are saying they
made a couple of pretty straightforward
points when I asked the question earlier
um echoing for one thing but a chairman
has said about
widening the gap between the solar farm
and Paul grave and they also commented
on the
on the on the
the whatever you call it the gap between
Millway and where the farm starts
um they commented that there is a line
of trees there which could be used as a
boundary for the sonar farm
so is the room to
throw it back at the applicant see if
they can come back with a with a with a
scheme which is more acceptable or less
unacceptable
a Gemma and that's a general comment
committee but as a question of whether
there is any room for a renegotiation
here
thank you yeah thanks Joe um
the opportunity to defer if there are
specific things they sound fairly
specific it might be something that we
could possibly refer to in that we might
be able to ask the applicant if this is
a remote possibility we could take it
away and we defer for particular ground
if it's a no this is our application
please determine it that that might lead
us somewhere differently
so does that mean you just need to go
and ask the applicant
do we just need to close the meeting
while you have a word or
yeah I think that might be helpful so if
we if we just have five minutes
um just to see if that is a viable
option let me just triple check if
that's right chair so what we are
thinking about is particular concerns
were with the proximity to the Village
particularly whether there's any wiggle
room there the setback to Millway and
moving the panels behind the tree line
was it also squaring off the field I
think there was something to do with the
square and off the foot I wasn't quite
sure what the meant maybe could we just
have the map up on the screen and just
to clarify what exactly we mean by
squaring off I think we're squaring up
was just to take the light where we've
got this diagonal line reaching up
towards pool grave if we just have a
look on the map just so that I can
visualize what you're looking at there
yeah yeah I just want to look look at
the at the map before we
specifically because that is the area
that is closest to
yeah
so how I suppose how far in is an
acceptable well I suppose if we did if
we did have the opportunity to defer it
maybe we could see what the applicant
how far back the applicant is prepared
to to bring that edge but anyway I'll
just have uh Council Lawrence I think
wants to come in
thank you uh yes I think don't think we
should forget the fact they also Drew
attention that there was a hamlet of
three houses surrounded on three sides
by solar panels and I'm a bit of
cautious on this Approach at the moment
because
um there doesn't seem to have been
willingness so we hear
um to negotiate with um
parishes
beforehand
and I'm not sure it's our position to
take on that negotiating position now
directly with the applicant here today
because how do we we don't know we could
come to see are we not digging ourselves
a hole like getting an approach and then
saying well we could agree to something
that the parishes still find uphold
was the parish have made their some
representations and I think they've got
some suggestions in their
representations haven't they
um
it's a you know or would would it if if
if we did
um uh ask the applicant to go back would
the parish then have um be able to to
read comment on the
resubmitted site plan yes I think we we
would probably send them a
reconsultation out um
yeah for them to comment on their
want to say something yeah that there is
a legal points but if an application
planning applications effectively
changed there are legal points to do
with whether it's so different that you
need to at the very least do
reconsultation to avoid unfairness
um I think those also make the point
replying to counselor Lawrence you
making any promises you can't legally
make interest of your success the next
committee which might not be exactly the
same membership anyway
so I think that's understood
so do do we just want to um close the
meeting for five minutes just for you to
um just see that is a a sensible
suggestion whether the applicant is
willing to reconsider thank you
uh thank you uh welcome back
um
so
um over to you Gemma
thank you chair uh thank you for that
time members much appreciated I think
that was a helpful conversation I think
we have had a conversation at the firms
they can make some amendments and some
of those would cover the issues that the
parish in particular raised
um so I'll let Jasmine run through the
amendments in a second but so we've got
some we can and some we we couldn't do
uh but if we could agree to that um
taking defer for amendments
such as we're talking about this will
obviously have to be confirmed would we
consult on those amendments to the
parish will get their opportunity to to
comment again and what we also like to
suggest is that we have
um we can
we can wording about optimizing grazing
for soil quality we've had a bit of a
further
conversation about that so hopefully
that's some reassurance that we we think
we could actually come up with a
conversation
safer than require it and that kind of
thing but we think we could come back
with some wording on that basis it's
unsuccessful but could we have a bit of
quiet because the sound quality in this
room is not good and it sort of Echoes
around and people are struggling to hear
so if if you're listening please could
you just be quiet because it's difficult
to hear over the hubbub thank you uh
Jazz uh yes thank you so in terms of the
Amendments I don't know if um
you get this
the
um right so in terms
the nice one I think yeah hang on
it's really terrible there we go right
and so one of the one of the Amendments
that could be made is this could be
pulled so this boundary here can be
pulled further in I think it would be a
total of about 120 meters is what we'd
be looking at from the edge of the
settlement boundary not from where
currently located which would mean I
mean there's 40 meters already between
there so it's it's pulling it further
back and so that's one of one of the
potential amendments
the uh grazing as well is something that
either the landowner or
um the applicant has already confirmed
they are planning to do it
um so it's it's a kind of either rule it
doesn't matter who does it it's likely
to be done anyway
um but notwithstanding that as as gem
has already confirmed we've been looking
to
um secure it via the soil management
kind of plan and roll into that because
that is pretty much the only way that it
would be a reasonable condition and meet
the sex tests to be imposed
um the only thing that is is not going
to be a viable amendment is that the uh
boundary for Mill Lane uh Millway Lane
even
um is is pulled further uh this has
already been amended and this is about
as far as it can go without and kind of
undermining the viability of the scheme
uh because a significant amount would
have to be called
um either way in either direction
um so that's that's basically a summary
of the Amendments
um so so basically what what I think uh
councilor hardingham was suggesting was
that we deferred it for
um the applicant to come back and
formalize that as a proposal and then we
would reconsider it another future
committee date and determine that on its
merits
to do yeah yeah
um so um
what I'm looking for councilor Lawrence
can I just ask all the parishes be and
residents be asked on these on these
changes will they be consulted
uh yes yes they'll be re-consulted
will that be another full six-week
consultation period or will it be a
compressed consultation period uh the
consultation period is actually only
ever a maximum of 21 days
um but I don't know if it would be 21 or
14 because for reconstations we tend to
do 14
um it would probably depend
I think we'd want to take that away and
confirm but we absolutely would be
looking to reconsult and I'm happy to
put that in the um resolution if that's
where members would like us to go
through
of course all the
um uh you know if it comes back to
committee or the parish council and the
objector will still have a chance to um
say their piece at a future committee
date as well
and there's no guarantee that we you
know it's still up to us to make the
determination of that future committee
so so uh Council hardingham singers you
made this suggestion are you willing to
make this as a formal proposal yeah
um for a re-consultation
we have some words Gemma yeah
absolutely do we need a second of first
before we get those words cancel Elkin
you're prepared to second
the amendment to the distance to the
village and recall reconsult on those
amendments
are you happy with that proposal and
seconder yes okay so can I now oh
councilor Mathison yeah I I while we
while we're tidying up and everything I
just wanted to ask whether um when it
comes back we can perhaps
um take on Council as well as request
for um the Skylark mitigation to be
specifically for the lifetime of the
solar farm
that's what he asked for
what what is the current Skylark
mitigation is that not they tend to be I
think it's about 10 years
as a standard thing across all
developments
um I'm not sure whether it would be
reasonable or necessary and I don't know
whether it would make this six tests
really of a condition yeah I think we
might struggle with that one so on a
Housing Development which is obviously
pretty permanent you're looking at only
10 years and it is a difficult one with
Skyline so I appreciate what they they
do move on so I know there's I think one
of the developments in Stone Market the
um the mitigation somewhere in this sax
mundum and you sort of think
that's quite a long way but apparently
according to the ecologists the the view
from up why up high is sufficient that
they will pick a field even in some
further distance and then not as
territorial as perhaps other species are
um and we can take it away and ask the
question but perhaps leave it off the
resolution if that's something members
of content with yeah quite happy with
that I mean I think that the officers
have got the opportunity to find out if
it's a reasonable condition or not
um and when they bring it back
right does anyone else have any other
things to say about the um revised this
new proposal for deferral anyone else
want to to say anything if not then I
will ask the governance officer to
conduct the electronic vote
um and I presume it's is it just as
written as just read out yeah I just
amended that to read the application be
deferred for the reasons as read out by
the area planning manager members that
vote is now in progress thank you
thank you members chair that's eight
votes for a deferral thank you so that's
um we'll we'll look forward to seeing uh
this one back in in Committee in a few
weeks time
um and I now propose that we stop for
lunch
um it's approximately half past one I
think the cafeteria canteen is open till
about two isn't it so
um it's 45 shall we say quarter past two
um it's not going to be long enough
um so if we if we take a break down
until quarter past two I'm sorry the the
bramford ones have had to wait um but
maybe it's been interesting listening
and I'll see you all again at quarter
past two thank you
uh thank you and welcome back after
lunch break
um we are now at item 7c which is DC
2104711 Land north of Thai Lane bramford
um and I will now invite the case
officer Brian Curtis to introduce the
application to the committee of our
teams
thank you chair
I will continue your Trifecta of solar
items for today with this presentation
so the application as you just heard
Land north of Thailand in bramford
this is referred to as the EDF
application the applicant is EDF
you have the site location plan on an
aerial view just so that you can see
context in relation to the main built up
area of Romford Village and you can just
see the National Grid substation off the
bottom there and the East Anglia one and
essentially a three sites
which I referred to in the Enzo
presentation this morning so you've got
you've got the context in in the area
and your site location plan gives a bit
more of that detail this plan is useful
to show the extensive right-of-way
Network in the area
um shown with the green dashed lines
which includes Roots passing through the
site
and adjacent to the site boundaries in
some cases
instraints plan showing that the site is
outside the designated special landscape
area but just a little way to the east
of that have some flood risk areas from
rivers and other watercourses just to
the north and east and again you can see
relationships the main built up here of
bramford
you can also see parts of other
settlements floating summer shim and the
rights of way Network on this image
this is slightly distorted but I was
trying to make it as large as possible
um this is the agricultural land
classification plan so the BMV with the
light yellowish color 3A
BMV and the dark greenish color 3B so
not BMV
the split is approximately 50 50.
oh that plan actually is also quite
useful to show the overhead route of the
overhead lines you'll see a lot more of
that in the photographs in a moment but
there's a lot of overhead lines that
come into bramford sub and they cross
close to and over this site in places as
you can see there
that just gives a bit of an idea of how
the development is laid out there's some
gaps through the center of the site to
allow for easement over Caden owned gas
Main
which is why there's not development
proposed across the entire site but
there are some spaces
you can also see in this image
gaps for oxen covert little
um
area of wooded
um and you've also got within the
applicant's ownership but not part of
the application site a agricultural pad
and grain store building
um
and then Copenhagen Hagen Cottage and
the associated Sage Hill
a little Sage Hill Campion Caravan site
is in this sort of triangular section
out here so that you can see that the
site goes around
with the boundaries of that property and
then you've got context with some of the
other properties that you can see along
Thailand
which is here
in summersham Road including Rutter's
Farm which is the grade two listed
building adjoining the site at this
point here
this plan is a plan that I showed you
earlier but it's the context for the
cumulative impact assessment again could
you just hang on a minute Ron um
counselor can we ask Ron to change her
cursor to red so we can see it a bit
better
is that possible can you do that thank
you
I'm not sure how to do that I think
honestly
right if you right click
they should only go to pointer options
and then it's the laser pointer
if you go to the laser one
hang on it's not let me get oh there it
is
there we go is that better
yeah
it's all right try to interrupt you
not a problem
um anything to make it easy to
understand a lot of information here
um so yeah this application is eia
development the same and for the same
reason as the Enzo and stackcraft have
been screened in a Zia on the basis of
the potential for cumulative effects so
uh it doesn't make any difference to the
way that we deal with the applications
and the consideration that we give to
the various issues it makes a difference
the way we ask the applicant to assess
the various issues and the type of
information that they submit to us in
the form of an environmental statement
and I can confirm that we have notified
the Secretary of State of this eia
development and they have acknowledged
that and that the relevant time period
for that notification has lapsed
um Innovation drawings showing solar
panels this is just for benefit of
seeing the height of the panels
let's say you've got
um they're all very similar but um
slightly lower than enso and the ones
that you've heard about powergrave
earlier today so 2.4
with a lower lower
um height of 0.8
and then
um the access
point is from Thailand
raposo includes some improvements that
access to improve visibility so you can
just see beneath this dark gray the
existing access apron and existing
access track up to the agricultural pad
and grain store there
and then the dark gray is showing you
the proposed works
also on Thailand which I'll show you in
another slide in a second
are proposed
um passing Bays
which are these
I'm hoping that you can see these plans
okay
you've got a small addition to the
access apron works at the access to
create fasting based space there in
addition to the access and then also
slightly further down Thailand towards
the junction with the B triple one three
Lorraine Ray another passing Bay
proposed and then a third one
again closer down so I've split this
drawing into two just so that I can fit
it on and you can see so there's three
proposed in total between the site
access and the junction with Lorraine
way
this plan gives some indication of the
submitted proposed landscape mitigation
and I'll run through the advice that we
had um from your landscape advisor about
and what's in the recommendation in
terms of
um taking that on board and adding to
that
and so these other slides from this of
the site so this is starting at the um
the edge of the boundary of Rutter's
Farm you can just see their boundary
vegetation in the center left here
this is looking over the site as it as
it was at the time you can see the
pylons in the background
which go up and then around Copenhagen
cottage which sort of sits over
in that sort of center background
and then
turning around from that point looking
further
um northwards towards Little blakenham
looking over a bit more of the site so
again you see those
pylons
in the background
and then walking to where about where
those pylons are roughly there's a
footpath footpath number eight which is
the northern boundary of the site and
then looking back towards Brantford so
looking in the other direction from The
View that you've just seen
this is a view that I've stolen from
street view
um
from Thailand
looking you can just see
in the background here that is the
agricultural grain store with pad which
is served by the access point which is
to be the access for the development as
well but this is part of the field that
would have Solar Development on it and
you can see where I've described in the
report that some parts of Thailand have
mature vegetation and that views are
um are intermittent but there are other
structures of Thailand which are more
like this where they're fairly open
there is mitigation planting proposed
but this is the existing sort of view
and then the existing access to
that would be used for the site which
currently goes to the agricultural grain
store and pad
and that's just looking at it from a
slightly different angle
and that's looking across the site from
that little bit further up that access
point and right-of-way looking
northwards over the site
and you can just see you can see you can
get a better sense here of um the change
in level
and this is from that same point from
that access footpath
um looking West
and then moving West so going towards
the common I'm moving West
um and taking views across the site from
Thailand
moving up the hill
the point at which the pylons cross
and then at the western side of the site
there are parts of the footpath network
which are near to Thai Farm
and they um come through come through
the bound beside the boundaries of a
couple of properties and then they come
onto the site just off Thailand and then
go
um
around the site boundary
you can see so this is the highest part
of the site looking northwards
and then that view turned around
slightly looking East
and then I've got some visualization
images that I've taken from the lvia
documents that were submitted
um and some wider landscape views in
here so you can see this is again from
so back onto the sunshine road at
footpath eight
and you can see uh the immediate parcel
of land at that point is not part of the
application site it's sort of a triangle
that's excluded but there's um the
panels
in the center background as they would
likely appear
from that viewpoint
this is a wider landscape View at the
footpath at little blaton Hall of Kings
South towards the site
so you're getting a sense of wirescape
and a rural landscape here in undulation
of the landscape
and again this is a visualization of you
so similar point the footpath that you
feel like in a hole and you're looking
towards the site you can see the panels
uh superimposed onto the pick onto the
image to see what it would look like in
that view
and then we've got a wider landscape
View
taken from the footpath just south of
summersham looking Southeast towards the
site this is the view as is
and this is the visualization so you can
see the difference you can really see is
that that is part of the site that's
visible where that
tree is and behind that
not green now
panel colored
in the visualization
and from the images that I showed you at
the footpaths close to Thai House
that are on the highest um and western
part of the site
visualization of
the development there
and I've included
um this image of the junction of
Thailand and Lorraine way the beach have
one three because this part of the road
in particular down here
um
gets a lot of surface water flooding and
there's a lot of concerns that have come
from objectives
regarding the impact of the development
on that
the information on
um generation
so the approximate electricity needs of
14 and a half that's 14 and a half
thousand it's not 145 I was trigger
happy with the zeros I'm afraid and a
half thousand average households and
that might also be a trigger happy I'll
double check that the cot offset
that is to remind me to talk to you
about sheep if we get to it
um I'll just run through
the
late papers
sorry the tabled papers because as well
as what you have on your
[Music]
um
on the file before the uh before the
agenda was published we've had
some additional papers that came in
um earlier this week
so
in your tabled papers you have a
representation from Mr Ballard
which you've probably had chance to read
in just in very brief summary it deal it
deals with the interpretation of policy
and how that applies to the
determination of the application
then a representation from Wilson Ray
on behalf of little Sage Hill Caravan
and campsite that's like Copenhagen
cottage which let me just
show you where that is
again so you can see because they are
concerned about
oh sorry Winter's gone again
so there
um
and again there's various matters on how
the report has been
written and how the matters are
presented to you that are raised on
their behalf
that party have also submitted a
document which is entitled to speech
from them which is not accepted as a
table paper because it comes from the
same party
um but it is on the file
and it
gives
a commentary on what it might be like to
be a guest at the Caravan and campsite
in respect of the issues that are
already raised on behalf of this party
by their agent in the Wilson rate letter
so there's not not really
um
anything substantively different about
the issues that they're raising but if
you'd like me to go into the details of
their speech in a moment I can do
and you'll also have a representation
from Care Suffolk
which has again various issues regarding
matters that are in the reporting
matters that are in the submission which
no doubt you've had a chance to read
already and then at page 29 There's a
summary of the appendices that were
submitted with that representation
which are um
letters from D luck and Natural England
in respect of inquiries to do with the
impact of Solar Development on
soil quality
and the other three appendices are
appeal decisions all of which have been
added to your summary of appeals
document which is then further down that
page starting on page 29.
uh so
the
we're in the same Realms of principal
Etc that you've already heard previously
today in terms of renewable energy
development
what we're dealing with now obviously is
a different site and a different set of
impacts
the
number of concerns that we've had from
objectives and other interested parties
range
across the whole whole issue of the
different material considerations
some of the most significant of those
I'll just summarize you'll have had a
chance to read the report and and can
obviously ask any questions but you can
see from this image and as we've already
touched on previously one of the most
significant impacts from Solar
Development is its visual impact in the
landscape I've shown you some of the
images of the site and surrounding area
so you can get a sense of how open the
site is to some views
particularly from the rights of way
because they are immediate direct and
open as they currently are you can also
get a sense hopefully from those photos
and what I've described of how the land
how the site sits within the landscape
and how the landscape is experienced
and so you should hopefully be able to
get a sense of the impact of the
development changing from changing the
site from its current
agricultural arable land to being used
for solar generation
the conclusion as you see in your report
is that the advice from the landscape
advisor is that it's inevitable that
there would be a significant adverse
impact
that is accepted that there is going to
be a significant adverse landscape
impact from The Proposal
and you'll see how I've dealt with that
in the weighing of the planning balance
overall against public benefits
moving on then to
um users of Rights of way there's also
been concerns about the impacts that the
development would have on the experience
of Rights of way users
and as you can see from this slide where
the rights of way Network passes there's
an extensive right away Network lots of
different options for walking routes and
those pass through the site and adjacent
to the site
again those visual impacts will be
experienced most predominantly from
users the right way
um there is a degree of mitigation
proposed in terms of some mitigatory
visual planting and you can see in the
recommendation information board
strategy which is a similar approach
that we've taken with the enso decision
so following the same
the same sort of route or that
moving on to Heritage enlisted buildings
the applicant is submitted substantial
evidence relating to archaeological
deposits
now to the satisfaction of the County
Council subject conditions
where you can deal
easily with
with that and ensure that we are
safeguarding
in accordance with policy below ground
assets
there are listed buildings and buildings
that are claimed to be undesignated
Heritage Assets in The Wider landscape
which have been assessed that the most
impacted is ray two listed Russia's Farm
which is directly adjacent to the site
here in the corner on summersham road
and there are other
um buildings which I've listed in the
Heritage section
overall advice from your heritage
advisor is that there would be a low
level of less than some potential harm
and I've carried out the weighing
exercise that's required
um by the mpps and the relevant
legislation
in terms of the
um
balance of that harm against the public
benefits of the development
there has also been concerns regarding
flood risk
I take back to the I'm not know this way
constraints plan so
the site is in flood zone one
um for fluvial flooding so that's
flooding from Rivers you can see the
motor courses are over here
the information we have from the
environment agency and the LFA don't
actually show any surface water flood
risk for the site but the applicant has
submitted a site-specific flood risk
assessment which does reveal
some susceptibility surface water
flooding particularly along the Thailand
boundary of the site and you'll have
seen from the photographs the levels of
the site and the way that the land falls
down towards Thailand because of the um
the agricultural nature of the site as
it is that um is what's called flashy it
means that if there's a lot of rainfall
that percolates through the soil very
easily and quickly and then onto the
road as the lowest point
and as I said that there's um there's
been a number of incidents of surface
water flooding reported along the
highway
the development includes measures to
control surface water runoff and to
ensure that the rate
that exists is maintained and improved
where it is along Thailand
you can see that you've got a
recommendation for a surface water
drainage scheme to be agreed so that we
can ensure the proposal is for swales
along this southern boundary with
Thailand to ensure that surface water
runoff doesn't then make it onto the
road as a result of the development
you've got other matters in the report
that deal with things like noise
um and residential immunity
biodiversity
I have put in the report that I would
give you an update on matters of Skylark
mitigation
because at the time of writing we still
had to resolve that with between the uh
the applicant and our ecologist advisor
we do now have submitted an outline
mitigation strategy that's still with
the ecologist just to confirm that he
satisfied but he has advised that that's
likely to be something that he can
accept and that he would confirm
conditions so I'd just like to clarify
the recommendation in your papers
is a we're looking for a minded to
resolution today rather than a decision
and then a delegation of that decision
to the chief planning officer once we
have resolved to the satisfaction of the
chief planning officer and the ecologist
advisor those matters relating to
skylarks
I'll leave it there for the moment thank
you
thank you
um do we have any questions for members
councilor penny
yeah it doesn't appear that the
agricultural grain store has solar
panels on its roof
um
will it have could it be included as
part of this development to show
[Music]
um
that they can be mounted on roofs too
um it doesn't have
not part red line site of this
development and is not part of the
description of this development so it
doesn't fall within the scope of this
application or the decision you'll be
making today
the policy that you have in your core
strategy
requires new buildings of over
I think it's ten thousand one thousand
ten thousand square meters to have 10 of
its energy needs met by renewable
sources
so that building would have been too
small for that whenever it was built it
was very likely a PD building anyway
meaning that we just don't have the
control over it that I think you're
seeking counselor but I will certainly
leave to the applicant whether they are
willing to offer anything unilaterally
okay
um any any I I got your hand there
Council Caston are any of the other
members of planning committee got a
question
uh councilor Elkin
I heard some concerns from the owners of
the campsite on various grounds one of
which was that they would be impacted by
flooding or it could be and they
mentioned that there wasn't any drainage
included in the plans
them specifically I just wondered if you
could clarify
that for us a little bit you mentioned
swales being added to stop more
about the the campsite I think
thank you so the records of surface
water flooding incidents
are only on Thailand as have been
reported
and are available to us so that is where
the highest risk of that instant
occurring is which is why the majority
of the design of the surface water
drainage strategy focuses on that part
of the site but the flood risk
assessment does show that they are able
to carry out the development whilst
maintaining the existing rate of runoff
therefore not increasing the existing
rate of runoff from the site to any
property Elsewhere One one of the
principles of flood risk in terms of
assessing development is that the
development should be safe for its
lifetime but should also not increase
flood risk elsewhere as an additional
Safeguard you have
a condition recommended to agree a
surface water drainage strategy with the
County council local lead local flood
Authority so the applicant will be
required to submit precise details of
how they're managing surface water and
we can
include specific provision for them to
demonstrate the impacts on Copenhagen
Cottage if if cancers feel that that's
necessary
a councilor hadtingham
I'm just a quickie Brian I'm back at um
the campsite they were talking about the
noise of the hum is it is that a true is
that a worry that they'd make hum the
whole time
um the with any electrical installation
there is a hum of in virgin in a very
general sense the noisiest thing about
solar developments that we tend to get
is when there is battery storage because
they come with
um fire suppression equipment that that
is more mechanical or this sort of
ventilation Etc there is no battery
storage proposed for this development
this is just solar
the application documents include a
noise impact assessment which has been
carried out in accordance with the
relevant British standards
assessed by your environmental health
offices and accepted as having no
observed effect which is the lowest
impact level that that assessment can
conclude in terms of background noise I
appreciate that the um
that the people who live at Copenhagen
Cottage and operate the business there
are also concerned about
visitors who might be sleeping under
canvas rather than
um
being in a building that might have
better sound attenuation because of its
fabric
the information that we have from the
noise assessment is that there would be
no discernible difference between the
existing background
um so it would there wouldn't not be
anything perceptible
as far as we're advised
okay cool thank you
Angela Matheson I think you had your
hand up yeah paragraph 10.5 glint and
glare
um
I see there that the um mitigation will
reduce
[Music]
when the planting um you know reducing
it after maturity and so on
um
the other application we've looked at
has temporary screening so that the
mitigation is satisfactory from the from
the from the outset and I wonder why we
shouldn't be conditioning the same thing
here
so you can see at 10.5 I'm the the
conclusion in the assessment is that
when the plant mitigation planting is
first planted
um that level of impact would be reduced
to low and then at maturity that level
of impact will be reduced to none
so I was concluding that that was
sufficient to deal with the degree of
risk but happy to take instruction from
councils if you feel we need to be a bit
tighter on that matter
right it is a little difficult to
understand how
um you know putting in some hedging or
something
um will you know given the height of the
panels and everything uh it's quite hard
to envisage actually and you know until
the edge of some years old
how it would have any effects at all
really
I can explain a little bit is to do with
the time of year the time of day and the
um degree at which the light hits the
panels and that which the panels are in
relation to the receptor and sometimes
those are so shallow that actually
something very small would achieve
something very quickly
thank you very much gentlemen through
you chair
um
is there any provision in this should in
12 years time the a much better
technology be available and um all of
those panels need to be changed for
something far more efficient or
um better in some way
um for obviously vehicle movements would
that be something that could just be
done or would that have to
be discussed by the council
that would need that would very likely
need a new application it would depend
exactly what was being proposed
um I'm thinking of some comparisons we
have had changes of tech which have
affected some of the battery storage
developments that we have permitted on
Bullen Lane
um which have been dealt with
by applications which are not referred
to committee
um and equally are not subject to public
consultation we could condition that
if members were concerned
it would depend on what was what was
being what the question was as to and
how significant material the difference
was that's the test the materiality
applications that don't require further
consultation are non-material amendments
so there are changes that are so small
as to not be a material change to the
scope of the permission that's already
granted and then you can have minor
material amendments which usually come
to us as something called the section 73
application A variation of the original
application to seek to agree alternative
drawings
or layout or whatever it may be
that would come back to you as a as a
renewable energy development under your
current scheme of Delegation
does that answer your question councilor
Kirsten yes thank you dear thank you uh
councilor penny
I was going to ask some things similar
to what councilor Castle has just asked
but also
on this application there's a temporary
limit of 35 years
whereas the other two we've looked at
was 40 years is it due to the quality of
the panels
I understand
my understanding is that it's to do with
the connection agreement with national
grid to export to the grid
predominantly
uh thank you if I may ask my couple of
questions
um can you please identify on the plan
the vehicular access to the campsite and
where Caravans are likely to be going
that's my first question
we've talked a lot about the
fact that it Copenhagen Cottage is
surrounded by the panels but how does
the Caravans actually get there
for on your own mute sorry
thank you I knew I'd do that at some
point today uh right uh so yeah where my
pointer is now
and I can show you the photos again if
you'd like to so that is the access to
the existing agricultural grain store
and Pad it's also a right-of-way and the
track goes up
to Copenhagen Hayden Cottage on the
campsite
here
so the access is there
and that's the reason why you have the
passing Bays the three passing Bays more
or less here here and here
to satisfy highways in terms of the um
construction period the six-month
construction period for the vehicles
that would potentially be meeting other
vehicles along Thailand during that
period
uh thank you and my other question
relates to Thai Lane
which I believe has been designated as a
quiet Lane and I think is part of the
national cycle Network
and has any uh any comments or
mitigation given that anything
registered as a quiet Lane is
effectively encouraging horse riders
pedestrians Runners cyclists to use it
I particularly during the construction
phase when there will be large trucks
and what have you going up albeit on
your short section but it's still part
of the um Quiet Lane
thank you so quiet Lane designation is
not a statutory designation but it is
acknowledging that the um the mixed-use
type nature of usually rural lanes for
cycling walking horse riding but that
those coexist with
um motorized vehicles as well
we do have a recommendation for a
construction transport management plan
we can very easily make that ensure that
it includes provision for the management
um of interactions with other users of
Thailand
and there's already proposals for
banksmen to deal with the interaction
with the rights of why users
I think it
the cycle Network route 48 which I I
think might actually only be a regional
cycle route but does that have any legal
standing
no
Mr Lawrence
I think thank you
um in the Care Suffolk supplementary
report in the supplementary agenda
on page 34 they make reference to the
mid-suffic council's 2018 settlement
sensitivity report
um and in that report it makes a
reference to uh to bramford and it says
um
this area is sensitive to development
where it appear visually prominent on
the valley slopes were where it would
appear visually bombing with islopes
development should not rise onto higher
undulations or Upper Valley slopes which
would be uncharacteristic
which would seemed to me in one area
we're going to say this is having a
significant impact on the landscape and
yet your report
seems to play that down
thank you um
I'm definitely concluding that there
would be a significant adverse impact on
the landscape I would like to be clear
that that is definitely the case that's
the advice that we've had from your
landscape advisor and that's the
conclusion in the report
the
assessment sensitivity assessment that's
referred to was carried out by Alison
farmer Associates
in the very
um
first pages of that report it explains
how to use the document and it says that
there is nothing no conclusions from the
report can be used to permit or refuse
development in its own right so it is a
contextual piece of information the same
as all other evidence-based documents
and information that we have to use to
build the context of
issues and material considerations in
the assessment of any application
thank you
any further questions of the officer
councilor Elkin
um
coming back to the campsite again I just
wonder
they're obviously sufficiently worried
about the change to their location that
you know they fear they could basically
be put out of business I just wondered
um if your Economic Development
colleagues had any thoughts on on that
if it's yeah if you could advise us on
how we should weigh that up obviously we
can't predict the future but if there's
any any guidance you could give us that
will be helpful
there hasn't been any concerns raised
directly from our economic development
team obviously you've seen the concerns
raised by The Operators of the the
campsite Caravan site themselves
it might be relevant at this point to
refer to the conclusions of the
inspector in the enso appeal because
matters of impacts on tourism came up in
that application as well in which he
gave a general view of all of the
um economic type impacts of the
development that there would actually be
job creation as well as
um as well as any perceived negative
impacts and that he concluded that he
didn't feel that the development in its
own right would be something that would
dissuade
people from taking a holiday I
appreciate this is different because
there is a different relationship of the
site to the the tourist site but
I think um it might be worth just
considering
that in the rounds of what already
exists in the landscape so you can see
from this image
the root of the pylons
and the fact that
this has agricultural land we have very
limited control over what could happen
there
so there could be very intensive
spraying and working of the land which
would be different after this
development I'm not saying it would be
better or worse but there would be a
different type of impact from there not
being
um noisy animals for example pig wearing
particularly noisy
um or something like that which I think
becomes difficult because it becomes
very subjective as to what you consider
something that would dissuade you from
taking a holiday somewhere personally I
wouldn't mind going on holiday somewhere
near solar panels but that's probably
just me
thank you
um is there a no uh counselor
hardingham
thank you um I'm I'm just going about
the impact on Thailand I think we're all
familiar with the effect on a narrow
Country Lane like that of having
suddenly a whole lot of extra
construction traffic going along it how
the verges get eroded and so on and the
road gets wider and wider is there any
possibility of a reinstatement scheme to
return Thailand to its original
condition
once construction work is over
we can certainly
um consider that as part of the
construction transport management plan
um
I'll just remind you that there are
three additional passing Bays being
proposed as part of the development
um that's in response to the advice from
Suffolk County Council
who subject to conditions to also secure
appropriate access visibility Etc
um were satisfied that there would not
be
um an impact that would reach the mpps
threshold for refusal on Highway grounds
which has to be
um a significant adverse
yeah I I um I was going to come back to
it when we got around to conditions and
things but there is actually
um a condition
recommended for repairs to any Highway
damage and I've got a note that I've
added on to that
I was going to suggest to the parish
councils around about
they took photographs before the start
of the work because I recalled a
situation like that involving A14
diversions in fact in the chairs
parachute and I think
um where um
you know getting the getting the
evidence beforehand was extremely
valuable so I think we have covered that
to a point already
um as it happens in in the conditions
that wasn't really a question that was
more an observation I think yeah but uh
anyway whilst we're on the subject of
the Thailand
um and the proposed passing Bays
um Thailand looks to me as if it's
slightly sunk in Lane with quite
um extensive trees on one side
um can we be assured that the creation
of the passing Bays is not going to
result in any loss of Hedgerow or trees
thank you chair so you can see from the
plan showing the passing Bays that
they're all on the Northern side which
is within the application site and
therefore within the control of the
applicant
um as well as the highly authority to
some extent it being part part Highway
land so there is then the potential for
uh well the the proposed condition for
landscaping will include Landscaping
behind those works so of the of the
development that is the panels rather
than the development is the passing base
if that makes sense so there would be
screening controlled between the passing
bays and the panels
to the north so so assuming that means
that some of those that uh
older hedge trees are likely to be
removed
their minimum will get them replaced
with other screening but I guess that's
something for later uh if there are no
further questions from members uh we'll
now invite the public speakers to
address the committee and again we have
Branford Parish Council Caroline Walton
same again uh from this morning thank
you
Romford Parish Council need for and
however not at any cost and disregard to
the community hosting it this
application sprawls over multiple
agricultural Fields producing crops for
our ever-growing population Fields
classed as best and most versatile the
agricultural production would cease
completely because EDF are asking for a
change of land use
destroyed the most protected habitats of
the skylarks which we've already spoke
about and hopefully is already being
covered and the development would sit on
High Valley slopes and an open Plateau
obliterating panoramic and long-distance
rural vistas of rolling Countryside
Hills your landscape officer stated
there would be significant landscape
harm and proposed screening was
inadequate residents of Brantford and
visitors will be greatly affected
visually as it will be seen from many
homes in the village and nearby Ipswich
as well as adjacent to a main route to
and from the village along the B triple
one three
the site engulfs three sides of little
Sage Hill Caravan site and Copenhagen
Cottage the noise intrusion true success
disruption Wildlife displacement and
loss of rural identify identity
threatens the existence of this local
tourist business which Prides itself on
being a relaxing getaway
other businesses and private residences
including grade 2 listed Rutter's Farm
also have panels within a few meters of
their Garden boundary and Heritage
settings a planted buffer is not a
sufficient solution as the development
Rises onto higher undulations in the
Upper Valley slopes which would remain
highly visible
the applicant has listed Thailand as the
access road to the site with no
alternative Brantford Parish Council
highways and even the site manager of a
contractor already working on site has
expressed great concern regarding this
road access it is a single Trek Road and
a designated Quiet Lane and National
cycle route with no pavement few passing
places blind bends and blind Hills it is
an inappropriate for the numerous
scheduled hgvs and would be a danger to
vulnerable users this is cause for
refusal
accumulative impact is overwhelming 210
acres here 86 acres by Enzo and 122
acres by stackcraft all solar facilities
pending adjacent to each other in
Brantford and neighboring parishes will
be over developed our village will have
no Countryside left
this application clearly contravenes
numerous policies in the local
development plan there is no exceptional
reason for this development at this
location cumulative impact and
encroachment is of great concern and
keeps being ignored we ask that you
listen to the community and refuse this
application thank you
thank you uh do we have any questions of
the parish council
uh no okay so we'll move on to an
objector Mr Derek Mayhew
um if you would like to press the button
and uh you'll have your three minutes
thank you
light on oh yes I have yeah can I just
say for start um
um I'm Derek Mayu I am a local resident
the member of Care Suffolk
um and we actually live on the site in
uh well what I call the epicenter I
think of the um solar panels surrounded
on if they go ahead on three sides but I
speak today
on behalf of little Sage Hill caravan
and camping site at Copenhagen Cottage
this is a certified caravan and camping
site site with a total of five Caravans
and 10 10 pictures rebuttal letters in
response to the case officers
recommendations have identified serious
shortcomings in relation to the weight
given in the planning balance to
principles of development and many Ian
tourism land Quality Landscape impact
highway safety flood risk protected
species and Heritage impact
the campsite is marketed as being a
hideaway in the middle of beautiful
Suffolk Countryside and is described as
follows on the caravan and camping club
website
here in the beautiful Suffolk
Countryside you will find peace quiet
and abundance of Wildlife and be
surrounded by many and various species
of trees and plants
Copenhagen Cottage is located as we're
seeing close to the northern boundary of
the site at distance so 80 meters from
this proposed solar panels surrounded on
three sides again the same as we are the
camping Caravan site that joins the
garden areas to the east of the property
simply put the reason for operating a
camping caravone site in this location
will be removed should this application
be approved the impact on a mean that
you will be significant at least
significant and the change in Outlook
for guests from Open Fields to solar
panels threatens the very existence of
this business as it will no longer be a
tranquil rural tourist destination
the recommendation reached in the
committee report has not sought to apply
any weight to the planning balance to
the impact of proposals on this business
or the impact upon the rural economy
should this visitor attraction be forced
to close we feel this is a serious
oversight and the planning balance
should be reassessed
in 2018 a settlement sensitivity
assessment which somebody else has
talked about was carried out by this
very Council in conjunction with two
others it separates the fringes of
Branford into three areas area bf1 being
relevant to this proposal
the assessment stated that the land is
valued as a rural landscape setting to
the Village which reinforces the
location of the settlement within the
gipping valley and it goes on to
conclude that this area is sensitive to
development where it would appear
visually prominent on the valley slopes
exactly what this um one is suggesting
today development should not rise on the
higher undulations or Upper Valley
slopes which would be uncharacteristic
overall this highly sensitive landscape
is entirely inappropriate for a large
solar farm we ask councilors today to
use their judgment and not and take note
of the numerous objections from the
community and Parish councils
the need for renewable energy should not
be automatically overriding
Environmental Protections and the
amenity of local communities
the planning balance reached in the
committee report needs to be challenged
as the negative impacts of the
development when viewed individually or
cumulatively outweigh the claim public
benefits of the development the proposes
a country to both National and planning
policy has requested the application be
refused
okay do we have a
half as of Mr Mayhew
uh councilor Mathison yeah Mr Mayhew
just just um
clarify reiterate what was the document
mid-suffered document that you were
quoting from the mid-southing document
was
I think the full details are are in the
um
full details of the document are
in the submission that the um consult
the planning consultant sent into
committee if
yeah in the late papers
you said it was in the late papers this
the one that came from Wilson and Wright
I think
courtesy of um Copenhagen Cottage
the full details are in there but it's a
2018 settlement sensitivity assessment I
think the same as one of the council
speaking of earlier
thank you settlement sensitivity
assessment 2019 it was
um do we do do we know what the status
of this document is
um I'm looking to you Gemma
I think this is the one Bron had
mentioned um
scrolling through because there is a
section that says how to use uh there we
go um
[Music]
it is an Evidence document a background
evidence document to the emerging jlp
and and the as I explained a few moments
ago the opening sections of how to use
the document
says that none of the conclusions in the
document should be used to either
approve or refuse
does that help
uh counselor
having a
this is probably to Braun or to um Gemma
but um it might not even be relevant but
I'm just thinking about you know this
business here potentially you know
having no clients in the future where is
the proposal formerly known as snow
Oasis
you know in this old thing is it like 10
miles away or is it vaguely in the
location because that is going to
involve a lot more jobs if it does
indeed go ahead
might let Brawn put the map up for that
one if she's still there we go
yeah I'm just looking I don't think I've
got it on any of my images so if you
just bear with me and I'll get you a
aerial view from Google give me a second
you're mute again um if you're saying
anything Brown
sorry I was saying really really
interesting things as well uh let me do
that again Thailand So currently in the
center of that
where the site is
you've got the Sterling the Tomato
Greenhouse you've got the port one
development and the areas for snow Aces
so I'll just zoom that out so you can
see the context
looks like it's about two miles
and do a quick measure if you like I
have brought I made it just short of two
so pretty much about one two miles
uh any further questions
thank you
um so uh we're now uh we don't have a
supporter here we do have the agent
Darren
um if you'd like to have your three
minutes thank you
councilors my name Darren and
I'm here to speak on behalf of EDF
Renewables who are developing the
Thailand solar farm I've been involved
in the Thailand project from the start
and they've helped formulate the project
that is before you today
EDF Renewables is developing a number of
renewable projects throughout the UK
including on and offshore wind storage
hydrogen and solar Farms such as
Thailand
Renewables will help us move towards net
zero and Thailand will provide a clean
low carbon energy for over 14 and a half
thousand suffer Combs
we have chosen Thailand carefully in
order to reduce the impacts of the solar
farm on the environment and the local
community we've used the local Suffolk
consultant to shape and guide our
project in a sensitive manner
we have carried out a consultation
exercise to ensure local people know
about our scheme and have changed our
scheme to try and take account of these
views
I personally visited some of the closest
properties to the site and worked with
our landscape advisors to land on the
most appropriate mitigation to protect
these properties
we work closely with your officers and
are pleased that the application has
been recommended for for approval
we have also been Keen to ensure we do
everything with that's been asked of us
which has included carrying out
additional ecology surveys and also an
extensive archaeological trenching
exercise
we will deliver substantial landscape
improvements to mitigate any impacts on
the local area as well as significant
biodiversity Net game well above the
required standard
EDF Renewables is an experienced
developer that's constricted a number of
Renewables projects across the UK as a
developer we do understand the concerns
of the local community and individual
residents
this means that we will work with the
council the parish councils and the
local community to ensure we build our
projects in the safest way possible
we'll do this by carrying out our
Construction in accordance with a
detailed planning conditions and
respecting the people who live near our
project
we do care about our projects and the
people who live near them and want to
ensure that we have an extremely good
working relationship
EDF Renewables will operate the solar
farm for 35 years and offer a Community
Fund of at least twenty thousand pounds
a year throughout the life of the
project we will deliver the benefits
that we say we will
we have a firm grid connection at the
nearby brownford substation which will
enable us to start generating clean low
carbon electricity at Thailand in 2025
we believe that Thailand is an excellent
site for a solar farm and strikes a
balance between the need for low carbon
energy and the environmental and
Community impacts
I'd just like to thank the committee for
giving me the time to talk today and
appreciate that the difficult job you
have before yourselves and I think
that's three minutes Jeff thank you well
according to my time you're under three
minutes so well done
um do we have any questions of the agent
uh councilor Mathison
thank you yeah
um I got two two questions really the
first one really uh does simple one
really
um
the the
um the community benefit is noted um it
seems modest
um Can it can it be inflation linked
please
through YouTube just just I I work 3DF
Renewables I'm not I'm not their agent
but in terms of the Community Fund
that's twenty thousand pound per annum
so over the life of the project seven
hundred thousand pound and I'm not
comparing anything to the other project
that you have but it's double what was
proposed there and that is a link to
inflation uh throughout the term of that
Community Fund
do you have another question yeah yeah
this is um this is rather different
um we
we've learned from news reports and so
on that the
um the grid has has
um
capacity difficulties at the you know at
the local level and and more widely
um so
presumably you've got an agreement with
them basically to connect
um so I'm wondering about the
um you know are you able to proceed and
connect this
as soon as it's built if you start
building it
shortly
um and um and also is that
is that ability to connect
um
politely to be constrained by
putting in the the transmission
essentially the transmission to London
in particular
um and and that how quickly that goes
forward and and also if that
transmission becomes
um an offshore
essentially offshore operation rather
than the the pylons which run through
through Brantford
um will that affect those issues
that through you again Chad we we have a
firm grid connection for the bramford
substation from National Grid uh which
is now currently for 2025. uh we did
have an earlier date for that but
obviously it's taking time to to bring
the application before yourselves today
but that is a firm connection offer
um in terms of The Wider upgrades that
will not affect the availability of that
grid connection the cut the connection
offer we have with natural grid is for
2025.
preempted me a little bit you mentioned
the brownford substation thought where
whereabouts is it in Bradford
high level you could it will it be an
underground connection to the substation
or
no the connection from the solar farm to
Brantford substation is an underground
cable across agricultural land uh to to
the South
um you know which is part of this plan
application and will connect direct into
into the Branford substation
coming back to Thailand and we've seen
that it's going to have overtake it um
you know bays at the side and you sound
confident that this is a good spot to to
build a large sonar Farm I'm just
slightly curious in a single track
tiny Lane what happens when a big lorry
meets a toad Caravan coming in the other
direction we've heard that there are
bends on the lane and it's it's clearly
quite a very tiny leafy route so yeah
good to hear about that you know I think
that's a good point counselor in terms
of you know highway safety and it's
something that is very important to EDF
Renewables we want to carry out our
projects in the safest way possible for
for local residents and users of of
Thailand you know obviously we have
consulted with the County Council and
and saw improvements to Thailand to
ensure that we can manage any transport
conflict along there
um in the use of passing bays and also
improving the access to
um to the site and also which would then
lead up to
um Copenhagen Cottage in terms of then
uh the actual when we start construction
of the project we will enter into a
detailed traffic management plan with
the council and ensure that that is is
carried out to the letter of that
agreement to ensure that we we reduce
any conflicts during when we're
constructing that project
can I ask her yeah ask her a second
um
just for somebody who isn't you used to
sort of the plans that you mentioned
held the ground what does that mean if
I'm driving my Caravan away from the
campsite I can't reverse what what
actually physically happens if I meet a
big big lorry bringing materials the
other way I
think so so during during construction
you
know where we build our solar Farms we
we ensure that the local community
including local businesses know when our
deliveries are going to happen that can
either happen on our website or via a
text message approach so when people so
people using those Lanes can understand
when they are likely to be bigger
and clearly as we know that the
Copenhagen Cottage camps um has got five
Caravans you know from from our
perspective we can manage that to ensure
we can work closely with your operators
of the campsite to ensure if people are
coming in that we can manage that and I
I've met the owners of Copenhagen
Cottage and also given a commitment from
EDF that during construction and the
operational phase that we want to work
with them and try and understand how
their business works and how we can help
help ensure that our project doesn't
have any impacts on them
thank you Council penny
yeah further to your discussions with
the owners of Copenhagen Cottage in the
Caravan and campsite
have have you discussed with them any um
financial
compensation for potential loss of
Revenue should they not be able to
continue with their business
we we have uh you know I've given a
commitment on behalf of EDF Renewables
if during construction that the campsite
isn't you know if there are major issues
you know in terms of use of that during
construction that we will seek to reach
agreement with them uh over that whether
that's a financial Arrangement it's
something to be discussed obviously you
know in terms of you know whether we get
approval today that will that will
trigger those discussions with with your
operators of coping of the campsite
there as I say you know we want to have
a really good relationship with the
communities that we that we build our
projects in hence the Community Fund and
setting up a community liaison group
during the construction phase and
operational phase to manage the
Community Fund so it goes without saying
that that I will be you know should
should we be fortunate enough to get
permission today we'll be opening up a
dialogue with the operators of of the
campsite there to ensure we minimize any
impacts of our skills
okay
um anyone else got any questions
um I've just got a couple of things I'd
like to raise some of them may be more
for the officers in the previous
application for a solar farm before
lunch there was a bit of a discussion
about the fence
um it's your solar farm going to be have
a fence all the way around it
yeah it has a has a defense around it as
as the previous uh applications it does
incorporate the the mammal gates to
allow you know you know sort of the
smaller Wildlife to get through that and
permeate through the site
and my other query uh relates to the
highway the proposed Highway works with
the new passing Bays
um now I'm looking to to the officers
here presumably there will be a timing
issue to make sure that those passing
bays are constructed before you have any
major deliveries with hgvs and I and I
also think somebody mentioned I think it
may was it the parish or was it in one
of the letters that there's already been
some people working on the site
um so presumably The Works already
carried out being carried out on the
site are are smaller vehicles but but is
there some timing going to be a a time
constraint on making sure we get The
Passing base done first
uh yeah it looks like it I don't
probably might come in on top there but
uh the access Works off Highway
Improvement works and the construction
traffic
plan would both look to control that
okay any further questions councilor
hardingham
thank you yes I've got a question about
sheep
um
I know that the
um solar panels are only going to be two
and a half meters high at the top 800
bottom
um and there's been comments about that
make making it incompatible with sheep
grazing
um what are the reasons for lowering the
the panels uh I would presume it's
disability and Landscape
um but
um does this mean that the site will not
be grazed and if not how will the
vegetation be controlled
if they're going to have to be regular
mowing
streaming underneath the panels
how is it going to be managed
in terms of in terms of the
um potential for grazing the site will
have potential for grazing that is
something that you know we will discuss
with the the current landowner whether
they want wish to graze or whether them
you know if it's if it's a requirement
and we think that's the best way to to
manage the vegetation on site so the
site can you know
um accommodate grazing from sheep
there's no issue with that in terms of
the panels and the point you raise there
about why the panels are lower at 2.5
meters that was exactly
um in a way to reduce the visual impact
when we originally launched this project
um which a long time ago during covid
the panels are originally three meters
in height and we reduce that as in
response to the consultation exercise we
carried out but just to reiterate that
the site does have potential for grazing
and we are we will discuss that with the
landowner as I say if when once we our
site becomes operational
in my experience with sheep they're more
than capable of putting their
300 millimeters high so you will end up
with actually roof prints on the panels
and and they have quite hard Hoops I
would suspect they might do some damage
to the panels as well so I would suggest
that the Sheep grazing
might actually not be a realistic
proposition
can I come back there three years yeah
you've got to come down yeah typically
you would need the lower part of the
minimum of 800 millimeters at where the
panel is closest to the ground but
that's what we we are proposing
proposing proposing here so so what we
need to do is make sure that any
electrical cables are properly sort of
conduited and tucked away so the Sheep
can't
um sort of chew into those but 800
millimeters is is at the front of the
panel is is the recommended sort of
height for for sheep
uh councilor War boys
yeah I I I'm just quite sure having to
find out where Brownfield substations
I'm quite curious about how it's going
to be connected up I figured out it's
Brand's still there because we have
slide eight I'll explain why
hello yep give me a second eight did you
say eight I think so
that's it
back
sorry
oh it's seven eight sorry slide eight on
my that's it it's like
yeah the the Bradford substation is the
the black one at the bottom which is
just labeled electricity substation on
ours
um and you're going to connect it with
that with an underground cable across
farmland
uh that on my map I guess we've got
there there are Woods in the way the
roads
um
so do
how do you Pro propose or reince
um restoring the landscape after the um
installation of the cabling it will it
be
embedded in concrete like a high tension
cable or is it
uh through you again so in terms of the
route we've we've assessed the route
from uh and chosen the best route across
that Farmland to uh avoid any areas of
Woodland or any sensitive uh locations
under the roads we will uh directionally
drill so we won't actually dig up the
roads that we that we cross and in terms
of the trench for the cable we're
looking at you probably you know it
would be a meter or so wide in terms of
putting the the cable in there so in
terms of the restoration of the land
following the putting of that cable
would would have very little impact on
the on the Farmland that we we're
proposing the cable
if you've got a question
yes please chair
um so this is a education of a change of
land use from agricultural to solar farm
would this affect your ability to put
sheep on that land
I mean I've listened to what the the
your uh your planning officer say but
from our perspective it doesn't it
doesn't make I don't believe it makes a
difference from a planning perspective
agricultural is what is generally
permitted development so I it wouldn't
change you know the status of putting
any uh sheep on the land I don't know
whether
um the the brawn or or the other planet
would like to to send in it
perhaps leave that one for Brawn on the
grazing topic if you're still with this
you're a meat run hello yes I'm still
here
um yeah it's perfectly possible for both
to coexist and there wouldn't be any
implication for a planning perspective
in terms of description for development
if england was felt concerned about that
we could
um we could use and we could agree a
change of description and we could
um go down the similar route as the
power grave and insert applications and
call it mixed use
if that would give you greater Comfort
provided obviously that the applicant
was willing to agree to that change
thank you
um
if there are no further questions of the
agent we'll now go to the ward member
councilor James Caston
yeah thank you this is um I think the
most harmful of the Brantford solar and
Farms it's um a lot more obvious it's a
lot more apparent than some of the other
ones but I would like to just talk to
you if you indulge me a little bit about
the um
the land grading the land quality and
what it actually means because
um I know what we've heard from the
inspector
but I think I think this needs to be
taken a lot more seriously so we've got
84 hectares on this site and it's grade
three and grade 3B the 3B is 3B because
it's um intolerant to Drought the um so
in a in the ordinary year it probably
would be producing about the same
um the 3A
so um we make three assumptions that the
world's population will continue to
increase and by 2050 we'll be 20 larger
the world population and
um
half of those live by this kind of
system of food production
um
the um the quality land available is
being used at the moment to add more
quality land to the pot we need to
either we need to take down habitat or
biodiversity rich areas in other
countries to produce more quality land
or we grow on less higher quality land
the um I am
we we import 46 of our food in this
country the um
I've done a few numbers with this
because I think it's really important to
understand what this looks like at the
end I've called This Land able to
produce nine tons per hectare of wheat
which I think is quite conservative on
3A land this year I produced um 11 tons
per hectare
um quite regularly but we want to make
it sensible through the um through the
um
you know through the bad years and the
good years so nine tons produces 1.37
million loaves of bread
the um the less versatile land like 3C
will probably do about just under seven
tons a hectare and it will produce just
over a million it's um got exactly the
same carbon footprint per hectare
the um
you um
to fill the Surplus we need to find
another 189 tons a week which is 28
hectares all which will have a um its
own carbon footprint to produce less
food it's basically land is a factory
it's an efficient factor it's not an
efficient Factory so um syngenta did
some like them or love them or or hate
them sorry
um did some
um work looking into carbon Footprints
per hectare of Wheat and they found out
the best systems in the UK do about 2.7
tons of carbon per hectare the eu's a
little way behind they they it takes
more carbon to produce it but importing
from China and Russia quite often means
that it's 9.1 tons of carbon per hectare
of wheat that's grown just because the
way they produce their fertilizers the
way they do anything
um at best
in the best system we produce another 76
tons of carbon per year by moving off
this versatile land and um at the very
worst we import it at 255 extra tons of
carbon to produce the same amount of
loaves of bread on here
um
that over the life of this development
that's 10 000 tons of carbon that's come
out of nowhere just because we're not
putting solar Farms on Lower quality
land
the um none of this will come under ah
um carbon balance will it because we're
importing it we're importing it from
China and Russia it will just be a ton
of wheat the the carbon on it so it all
works very well for Net Zero importing
more food from other places with a
higher carbon footprint but not
recording it but I think you're all
reasonably familiar with how these
things work
but um
so that's the farming side of things the
the um the other side of things is like
the cheap grazing I think this cheap
grazing it's a bit of a myth it's um
you've you put two different types of
grass mixture into a um into a field you
either put a ruminant grazing mixture or
you put a recreational mixture one grows
very slowly and you don't have to cut it
all the time the other one gray is like
Madness and if the Sheep were ever
removed you'd be cutting it all the time
to try and stay on top of it so from the
very beginning these planning
applications unless we specify rumen and
grazing or similar grass on the at the
start of it it will be Recreation it
won't be anything like the efficiency of
a farm and it won't be that good a
quality the other thing is sheep are
actually quite violent
animals they do break things they um
they push against things like um
councilor hadron
hardened him sorry my apologies they
saluded to before and all this cost has
to be covered by the landowner so do if
you're if you're letting out the land
for someone to um put sheep on it that
that needs to be covered they could do a
thousand pounds worth of damage in an
afternoon so that's just something that
I've been um I've been looking at
I so the Enzo appeal is quite important
to this plan application everybody here
is following it very closely the um the
wording of that
um
I think he I think it's been quite
unfair the um the talk about
agricultural practices and soil erosion
and worms
um that you know the damage that modern
agriculture does I actually followed
this Farmer on social media and they
actually drill with um one of suffolk's
very own clade and drills which is a
zero till drill they drill straight into
the stubble they don't they don't turn
it over they spread
um compost from our way uh Brown waste
plant they they grow um
legume and herbal lathe you know farming
is very different I think I think the
inspector's been very unfair with how
he's
talked about Farmers there but what I
wanted to talk to you is about the
different parts of that
um that um appeal the results of that
appeal we heard about tourism and um
Braun said about that that was covered
and that was paragraph 60 three of their
no one can really argue that tourism
will be seriously affected by this site
but the actual wording that the
inspector uses
um is because this is a relatively small
Solar Development
that's the reason why he doesn't believe
that it would dissuade visitors from
visiting this is a very large one this
is 85 hectares in we can't look at that
and treat that in exactly the same way
this is different you know it's it's
four times the size
the other ones in there was the um
paragraph 36 and 35 and 37 to some
extent I know you can't look at these
while I'm saying them but I'll give you
a rough summary of what they are the
visual receptors citing the fact that
the backdrops and filtering would
mitigate the impact there are a few of
these there are a few of these in the
application
um this open aspect is really
significant to the landscape character
so this again this application is the
opposite to what he's talking about
there
um you know it's open it's not it's not
covered paragraph 39 The Proposal does
not affect the character and topography
meaning the ride of views would be
fleeting rather than seem in total this
to me is in total so again in paragraph
39 it's the opposite to what the inspect
said on the solar farm
um
I don't believe that the result of the
appeal means that everything has to be
looked at in exactly the same way as the
Enzo application this
um
I am
I think um I think we can especially if
there's going to be a lot of these solar
Farms I think we need to really look at
them and take out the bad ones and
if we go to appeal and we're allowing
solar Farms but we're picking out what
um certain solar farms for certain
reasons then we can still refuse them
that that will work and I'm not against
solar Farms because on on lesser quality
land I think they're fantastic the um
all those all those lines from the
Norwich to Tilbury lines that are going
in and the existing ones can connect
onto this we um we're basically
supplying mid suffix now supplying power
to um Norwich and Tilbury generating it
on our Fields it's our fields and their
energy
we can we can look anywhere down that
line and find bad land and put solar
Farms on attach them onto that um
Norwich to Tilbury line just like the um
previous application and um also we've
got to expect because of this Norwich to
Tilbury uh this um East Anglia green
they used to call it we've got to expect
this to turn into a much bigger
solar farm
um application situation because they
will have twice the capacity or
greater times the capacity so anyway
um
um if I I just don't want to see us
approve in everything because I think
then we're an open door we're a green
light to all this solar farm I'm as a
landowner I get a um one letter a week
saying do you want a solar farm on your
land and all the most of the farmers
that I've spoken to around are getting
exactly the same thing there will be
supply of solar Farms long enough
timeline but um
but also I just very quickly sorry in
the chair I know I don't want the time
limit to have to be brought in just
because of me and today but I just want
to say about the industrialization of
this area
um it will bring about permanent
features in the um appeal we've heard
how the pylons make it more acceptable
to have solar Farms solar Farms make it
more acceptable to have other
development so um we do have to really
watch that and um
the um
putting solar farms in the wrong place
will damage the public image of solar
Farms we want to work with people and we
want to take them with us and say look
this is fantastic we we're going to be
more energy
independent we're going to need need to
um rely on oil less where there's so
many great things that come with solar
generation so um I just don't want to
see it given a bad name and
them put in the wrong place so that
people are fed up with them before
they've even started so I will stop
talking then I apologize that I went on
a bit um yeah oh thank you take
questions uh well it was interesting to
hear hear your your figures actually
about about the productivity of land
because we don't you know we're not
Farmers we don't know stuff like that so
that was quite interesting thank you uh
does anyone have any questions of
counselor castan
you're just thinking don't let them talk
again no I think I think
uh thank you very much
um
we now need to open this item Up For
Debate so
um anybody like to say anything
counselor having them thank you
um I just want to say I think James has
got a good point do we have to say yes
to everything
the right place then we can say no to a
few of them I think this is the wrong
place you know I so feel for those poor
people at Copenhagen Cottage and and the
the campground you you know it's just
you know it looks like a disaster I
agree with James what you're saying
about you know we're just we're kicking
the the this into the long grass that we
think we're actually doing good for the
environment because we're not in the
long term it might not be on our little
tally sheet but it's certainly going on
in the world and you know that should
make some difference so that is my
opinion at the moment
thank you anyone else like to comment
councilor Mathison
yeah I I I want to first start to start
with some comments really
um
more generally I think today
and the previous the previous
um time we've discussed solar Farms you
know we are now learning more about the
detail the implications and so on and
and I think that counts the casting as
as contributed quite quite well to that
um I I certainly hadn't thought about
the
um you know which type of grass kind of
question I think that that if if the
area planning manager will just take
those thoughts on board about the the
the grass in terms of of first of the
the biodiversity
um that that we're we're looking to
achieve through this I mean there's a
very different result if you start off
with a meadow and stick the solar farm
on a meadow which is full of mixed
mixed herbage I think do we call it knit
and that sort of thing
um and whereas councilor Cassie talking
about you know do we do we sow this
grass or that grass into into an arable
field and that's that's a very
interesting thing that I hadn't thought
about before so that that's useful and I
think that works both in terms of the
biodiversity directly and also the the
effect on the soil quality which which I
think we've started to isolate as a
separate condition
um I think that those are two general
learning points I just wanted to to
emphasize actually
um apart from that yes this is a very
big
scheme and I you know I talked on the
previous one about well you know we
can't sort of draw a line once we
produce enough electricity for Suffolk
um
we will we have got advantages in
producing it for other people
um
but
that feeds into the transmission
argument as I said said earlier so there
needs to be
there needs to be sensible limits and
you know the other thing about the
learning curve is we're having to learn
very fast
um you know we might have had a lot of
time to learn gradually about more and
more about how to get good Housing
Development but with this stuff you know
we've gone from no solar Farms to lots
of applications you know all too quickly
I'm sure we're we're grateful to
um
a particular planning officer with us
today for doing a lot of the learning on
it as well
which she's um which she specialized in
but I really
it's it's hard to see
strong enough reasons
to to object to this one
um I think the the landscape cumulative
impact argument is going to come to Bear
pretty soon here
um because I think there's another one
is there or two in the vicinitys already
that we know about Gemma
there's definitely one isn't there
another one the stack craft I think it's
called statcraft that is already within
the planning system
or is that only at the
environmental impact stage I think that
was just scoping maybe Brian can help
yeah yeah so there's another yeah
application is in and running
with that does that mean we can take the
cumulative impact of the of of that into
consideration in our determination of
this
so that that's what that's all I'm I'm
saying about that that that's a slightly
you can point what I'm talking about is
another one of the things that we don't
have the tools to deal with and that's
um sequential development that that the
if this is
if this is the the worst
the least suitable out of four in the
area or something of which we've one's
already done
um
you know do you see the problem that if
we if counselor casting is right and
this is a particularly poor site
um
you know do we do we risk refusing this
one because we think the next one coming
down the road will be better
you know but we haven't really got
the sequential policy to say we think we
prefer the next one to this one we can't
really do that so I you know it's this
all makes it quite difficult but that is
things that we need to think about
thank you uh councilor hardingham
yeah well I've just been thinking about
and jotting down
um a list of of things about this
um this particular application for a
start for the land area it has an
extremely long perimeter
it's on you know it's very spread out
relatively thin
it's on rolling Countryside
so that it's actually highly visible
um
the The General
presumption for solar Farms that there
should be they're better on Plateau land
where views are less extensive
um
we've got the question of impact on
tourist business
we've got the impact on Thai Lane and
the enjoyment
um
of local residents and and visitors in
using Thailand the cycling and walking
and horse riding
they're a quite significant impact from
the public right-of-way netmark Network
um
there have been comments on the
potential damage to Millers would which
is an important
landscape asset ancient Woodland
because the I accept that they're going
to take the they're planning to take the
cable underneath it but maybe there is
still some potential impact
um
some of the The Neighbors
particular
Copenhagen Cottage and Rutter's
Farmhouse are going to be severely
hemmed in
by the by the development
we've got question marks as to whether
or not sheep grazing and agricultural
production is genuinely achievable on
this site with the height of the panels
um
and we've got the Skylark question as
well
so in my opinion there are cumulative
impacts of this development which make
it
relatively undesirable compared to for
instance the one that was allowed by the
inspector Mr Colin Parker I also note
that Mr Cullen Parker has recently
refused Persona Farm application on
appeal
so the president
um is not all one way
okay
anyone else like to contribute uh
councilor War boys
yeah so I think I must thank Council
Casa's comments too well I've sort of
been playing around with figures
um at times two in terms of
comparing uh food and energy
and I haven't come to any definitive
answers yet but the trend seems to be
that more households will benefit from
the energy produced than the actual food
is grown but as I said I'm open to
challenge some that
um
is this the right place
um in my feeling it it there are
arguments in favor of it in that we have
a cluster of solar Farms together and
substations
um
rather than sort of dotting them round
the landscape
collect keeping them together the
connectivity which is crucial to these
developments in in one place
um so I I think there are arguments in
favor of this being the right place it's
certainly the right time because that's
the other
uh fact in this we we are suffering from
an energy crisis which is driven driving
along other factors including importing
gas rather than we from from Russia
around the world
and the fact that this can be produced
in energy in two years time and feed it
into the National Grid
um
reduce the Reliance on gas and oil and
imported
um energy sources is is a very important
consideration and it certainly I think
the driving force behind the
government's stance on bringing forward
solo
arrays
um
I don't like seeing uh
Green Fields being
taken up
for industrialization if you like of the
landscape of introducing solar Farms but
I grew up in West Yorkshire West
Yorkshire is um
part of the
Industrial Revolution
um
not far from where I grew up there's
Breton Hall next to Breton Hall
there was an open cast coal mine
this was acres and acres and I remember
that being Richter and for coal and
decades later that land has been
reinstated this is a temporary
installation it's 30
um
five years
um from my point of view it's probably a
permanent
installation but nevertheless it is a
temporary installation similar to the
opencast mines
in in Yorkshire
um
which were a long time ago now 50 years
ago
um
we we have
the so we have an opportunity to
approve the application
which will go towards meeting if you
like the government's targets
one of the figures that is banded around
is if the government achieves all of its
Target of
electricity produced by solar Farms it
will still only have a very minor impact
on the available agriculture land less
impact than golf courses
um
and node at the moment is talking about
uh turning golf courses into allotments
to resolve our food crisis
we import 50 of our food we also export
food
um
and and that's I think a debate for a
different Forum we it's too
complicated if you like to think of it
in terms of we're going to resolve this
in in a planning meeting
um
I'm tempted to feel that this this we
should be approving this application
um we we know what the decisions of the
planning inspector talk I think
in lots of ways it is in the right place
there are impacts on on local industry
and I read the letter from the Caravan
site and I thought there are genuine
concerns and anxieties there but we've
heard from the developer
and they are prepared they are open to
negotiation with
um
local businesses in order to sort of
look at how they can sort of help
oh them
um
we we do have a very quite a romantic
view of the landscape I mean I live in
the middle of a sort of rural landscape
which is good enough Pilots watching
across it perhaps at some time in the
future it's not a quiet place you have
agricultural machine you have
um
work going on in the middle of the night
sometimes so and again you have roads
um the lane itself will be sort of
subject to agricultural Vehicles going
up and down it which are from from my
perspective very much HD real vehicles
um
so I I I'm tempted to think we should be
approving this application it does have
impact I think we're going a long way
towards minimizing that impact I I
we do need to do more research we have
got our local plan coming forward and we
do need to develop our policy with
regard to solar farms and
infrastructure projects generally but
we're not at that
situation yet
and this is a live project which could
provide in the electricity in two years
time
thank you
uh councilor Lawrence
I would like to take up and support
counselor Customs comments
um this is a scheme in my feeling we
should actually stand up be counted and
object to and if you're looking at the
appeal which was granted inspect you in
paragraph 42 when he's considering
negative cumulative impact
he says whilst noting the concerns of
interested parties as to other proposals
coming forward for solar farms in the
area the surrounding fields are still
tradition in traditional agricultural
uses such as elbow farming
it would be for the council to consider
proposals on those if or when they arise
there would not be so he's allowing us
to make decisions and consider the
cumulative impact of which this is
another scheme and his comment then goes
on to say there would not be a
proliferation of solar farm developments
arising as a result of this scheme
so he uses that weight apparently appeal
but he's not expecting
there to be a proliferation of solar
Farms why why did he make that comment
if he's not expecting us to take in
consideration the cumulative impact of
other farms in the area solar farms in
the area and we've already heard that
there's significant landscape impact and
I think we've got full justification for
refusing this on both cumulative and
Landscape impact
okay uh councilor Penny did I see your
hand got
yes I was just going to
um emphasize the concern that's already
been aired that due due to the nature of
the terrain in East Anglia we could
become
the end the energy producer
for the rest of the country and I'm
concerned that we do end up with more
than our fair share I don't see them
being
a feature of the landscape on the
Prairie that is the Cotswolds for
example or
other other parts of the country and I
do I do have concerns that if we
approve too many of these applications
then we will
as has just been said we will be swamped
with applications
uh councilor Matheson
yeah I I re yeah reflecting on on what
councilor Harding have said particularly
um and I'm just I'm You Know You Can't
Always Get Enough from the photographs I
occasionally driven through little Blake
in them and these these Villages here
and I think this is probably the time
when we should go and have a look
actually
so um I'd be interested to hear what
other people think but I think we should
actually have a site visit go and have a
look because that will give us a better
opportunity of trying to get our heads
around whether this is the
um you know the second best site in the
area or whether it's going to be the
fourth or fifth best sighting areas let
alone
the other places
um like
how grave like
um badly which we know and and others
that are on the list
um
so I I propose a site visit because
that's a formal proposal
otherwise it conforms
thank you
um
well as everyone's spoken other than me
about this or did you want to come in
councilor Elkin before I put my little
pellet I hadn't because I was listening
to everyone else and
um yeah it's a really different really
difficult one and I think a site visit
would be really helpful in this
particular case so I won't take up
everyone's time with saying more thanks
thank you um well we've got a proposal
for a site visit
um with a seconder
um and I'd just like to say I think
again we are we are in a very difficult
position
um and I do think I I welcome uh your
comments James James uh Castle custom
because
um it certainly made me think about what
you're saying about importing uh food
but of course that does have to be
offset with importing energy uh or an
important fuel from overseas so
um yeah I think it's a bit of swings and
roundabouts really and I I think I I
share a lot of my thoughts with
councilor War boys in the in the I think
it's very difficult for us to determine
whether this site is better than another
site or worse than another site but one
thing I I have no noticed about this
site uh in contrast with the powergrave
site where we saw that the applicant had
had made considerable inroads out of
from the edge of the plot of land to try
and mitigate for the Residential
Properties
and yet this site that we seem to have
got there on our little maps that blue
um shading where the panels are going to
go right up to the boundary of
Copenhagen Cottage and right up to the
boundary of Rutter's Farm now now maybe
maybe if if they put a little bit of
consideration and had a sort of um
exclusion zone or whatever you want to
call it around those Residential
Properties maybe that might have made it
slightly more acceptable and I do feel
for the um the Caravan site
um maybe I'm a bit like Braun and maybe
I'd actually want to go to a caravan
site and go and investigate some solar
panels but that's the engineering me I'm
sorry I'd be interested to go look at
the structure and the materials
um uh you know given that I did actually
do some work on solar panels long long
ago
um not that it came to any fruition but
I would actually be quite interesting to
go and investigate a load of solar
panels so maybe I'd be one of the ones
who'd actually want to go to a campsite
um just so I can look at them so there
will be people like me and Brian who
actually want to go and look at solar
panels
um but but yeah I do think maybe a
little bit more consideration of those
um
pulling away from the Residential
Properties and actually the access road
to this campsite will go right up that
track through the middle of the site
there's also a public footpath through
the sort of Western portion of the site
that is very looks like it's very hemmed
in with solar panels great for us as
Engineers who want to go look at how
it's made but maybe not so good for
people who want to appreciate the
countryside so so maybe I'd I'd actually
almost like to do what we've done for
the power grid one and ask them if
they'll pull back from the edges a
little bit
um but anyway we've got we've got a
proposal for a site visit which has been
seconded so we'll just have councilor
Elkins got anything more to say
yep
I've heard about different types of
grass use and I'd be really interested
to know if solar Farms need to be kept
short because if not the government a
different bit of government policy is is
paying landowners to put various
different brass mixes which have sort of
high levels of Wildflower you know eb8
and things like that
if something like that could something
like that work in a soap Farm you there
are restrictions on how often they can
be known or grazed so they do get quite
long but in terms of the biodiversity
impact it could be quite substantial to
have 90 hectares of that so it was just
a technical question whether that works
or not
might have to defer to EDF which we
might come to council the Mansell and
Ian if we're happy to do that I think
just to pick up on the types of grass
that councilor customer raised earlier
we do have the landtech management plan
so we would expect that as part of that
so our management and grazing plan we
would expect to be confirming what sort
of grass is going on there in terms of
high
yes
yes are you intending to ask them now or
or or what cannabis do you need that
information beforehandry come back or do
or can it be something that you go back
to them after we've had the vote on the
site visit you're happy to do that we
can ask and come back
yeah
and actually whilst I've got the floor
um can I also make the comment that
given that we've deferred the previous
the pelgrave application and we're about
to arrange a site visit for this
application and we do have our emerging
joint local plan which might carry more
weight by the time these both come back
to committee should should the site
visit proposal go ahead
um and we'll that now that that LP 25 or
whatever it was called did talk about
assessing other sites so so how would
that materialize if we're now saying
that perhaps some of us think that this
isn't the most suitable site will that
lp20 if LP 25 carries more weight next
time we discuss it
um will we be expecting the applicant to
have explained why this site is better
than the others
so yes what we've asked on all
applicants as we've been going through
gradually is said to them choppy is
emerging you need to answer this we need
a statement from you that goes through
how you think you can apply and this
this front should we be in that position
I did have a brief look through earlier
um I don't think that there was anything
that made me think oh that's a problem
under this one perhaps a little bit more
information here and there to comply
with the glp expectations and that would
be the next step assuming that the glps
move forward by the time we come back
after a site visit if that's what you're
interested thank you so um do we have
any further comments before we go to the
vote on the proposal for a site visit I
can't
I don't know if we're allowed to so I'm
just thinking whilst you might have us
all in the coach but if you were also
going to power grave and possibly to
look at what we know is coming up in the
system other sites or are we not allowed
to do that we've just got to go to one
place
uh
um I see no problem of going around the
other sites around this site uh in terms
of statcraft the possibly even the
substation if that's things you would
all like to see powergrave I think we
might need to make a decision on that
one
yeah so very happy to ask one to go
around to this area but I would keep it
to this site great so so we would be
able to incorporate uh visiting the the
statcraft proposal and the Enzo site and
the substation because of the cumulative
impact on this area
are we are we happy with that the
proposer and seconder for the site visit
so
um if no one else has got anything to
say I'll ask the governance officer to
conduct the electronic vote if you just
like to presumably it's we're reading
out that we're going on a site visit or
do we have to specify what we're going
on the site visit to look at
no we don't we don't need to do that
I've just changed the votes and say that
a slight visit be undertaken in respect
of and the application will return to
committee uh both is in progress members
members thank you members chair that's
eight votes for the site visit so that
will go ahead
um members I will speak to the case
officer tomorrow and we'll send some
information around about possible dates
then thank you
um so we we've still got another couple
of smaller applications to deal with but
I'm going to propose that we have a 10
minute Comfort break so can we meet back
here at uh 20 past four and we'll try
and get through those other two
applications we're not we're not we
don't
foreign
welcome back
um we have got two more applications to
do uh so we are now on item 7D DC
2302385 10 Silver Street old Newton
um and I will now invite the case
officer Nikita Mossman to introduce the
application to committee thank you
thank you Jan good afternoon members so
this is application
dc2302385 at 10 Silver Street in Old
Newton Stone Market The Proposal is for
the erection of a single story side
extension and a new entrance porch the
reason this application has been brought
to committee is as the site is on
Council own land
so this is the site location plan
showing the site in its context it is a
predominantly residential area and has
Silver Street running along the west of
the site and Faulkner Avenue on the east
this is the aerial map also
demonstrating the site in its
residential context
here is the constraints map showing the
settlement boundary line in brown this
also shows that the site is within a
medium to high density residential area
which has been which has many Council
owned properties in the vicinity which
are highlighted in purple
these are the existing elevations
showing the canopy structure in place on
the west elevation which is proposed to
be replaced by the new front porch on
the South and East Elevation drawings
you can see an existing Conservatory
that is to be retained
there are these are the proposed
elevations which show the flat roof
construction of both the port and the
extension it also shows the proposed
materials which are fiber cement
cladding on the walls with a brick
plinth and a single ply flat roof
membrane on the roof
this shows an existing floor plan on the
left and the proposed floor plan on the
right which shows the size of the
proposed extension and the porch as well
as the distance the extension would be
from the neighboring boundary
moving on to site photos the left shows
the existing front elevation and the
relationship between the dwelling and
the neighboring property as part of a
semi-detached pair the right shows the
existing closed boarded fence which
adjoins the dwelling
the picture on the left is a view of the
of the area behind the existing fence
and where the proposed extension would
be situated the picture on the right
shows the rear of the dwelling as well
as the existing Conservatory the side
extension is proposed to be in line with
the rear of the dwelling
the picture on the left shows the
boundary fence to the south of the site
which the side extension would be facing
onto and the picture on the right shows
the rear Garden air Garden area which
gives context of the scale of the site
the dwelling can only be accessed via a
footpath which is shown in the picture
on the left and the foot part is lined
with mature hedging along the side
closest to Silver Street and the other
side is fenced which marks the boundary
line of the site the picture on the
right shows the view from the dwelling
onto the footpath
as there is no on-site parking available
for the dwelling this picture shows that
the shared parking Bays which is to the
north of the site
and the red arrow shows the entrance to
the footpath which leads to the dwelling
in summary all the Consulting responses
that we have received have raised no
objections subject to condition and we
have also not received any local
representations
based on the details set out in the
report the recommendation is the grant
planning permission with conditions set
out in page 168 of the bundle thank you
uh thank you uh do we have any questions
of the officer councilman's grinning at
me
yeah um it used to be a tradition that
when a an officer came to the committee
for the first time that the chair
welcomed them but I would do that on her
behalf in this this time
um yeah welcome to the um planning
committee it was nice to see you
um yeah my my question really though is
um
just a one of puzzlement which is
probably not even a planning for this
question really is is why if this is a
council house which it had manifested
was on the plans a moment ago and is
because that's why it's here
um why why is the private householder
and their agent applying to to build
this extension on our Council house
I believe that the applicant has a
growing family and just wants to be able
to stay in the house and so they just
require some more living space to
accommodate the family that currently
lives there
it's not a surprise because it's not an
extra bedroom but um be that as it may
if this is effectively the housing
department
um bringing this forward are you here
from the housing department
okay
um then yeah fine okay that answers my
question
Council penny
Penny I'd just like to ask if this is a
normal
occurrence where
where onto Council houses
I think so
um
I think yeah that they can apply and
we've had a few applications where they
want extensions on Council houses so I
think it is something they can
yep thank you
tailing plan
Council as Housing Authority needs to
and landlord needs to agree to anything
like this and that would actually still
be the case if it was a right to buy
property because under the standard
covenants major changes need to be
agreed by the council
where I use London hat but I I did after
we spoke in briefing I Nikita and I have
spoken to housing officer colleagues and
we that they are aware of this this
isn't going to come as a whole
lot we don't need to say anything more
than that that there is
the job of the planning committee is to
decide whether this is a proper use of
the land and acceptable development
so I
take that should we be granting planning
permission it would then be up to the
householder to to liaise with the whole
housing department
um before they can actually start any
work does anyone else have any questions
if not can I just ask about the
construction management and the parking
area because clearly this is a older
stylist states where I'm I would imagine
parking provision is fairly restricted
for modern day uh car ownership and we
need to be very clear that when the
builders drop off any building materials
they do not they're only there
temporarily and then they they obviously
have to access the site via the foot
path and then take their vehicle away so
that they're not occupying the parking
spaces for the other residents and
presumably that will be incorporated in
our construction management plan
someone else's got a new thing to say
okay
we do not have anything from the parish
council or an objector or a supporter we
don't have the applicant
um the ward men one of the ward members
um has got a written statement uh so
I'll just read out the comment from
councilor Rachel eberne
um who has said that this application is
before committee as it is owned by
mid-suffolk District Council I would
like to reiterate the parish council's
concerns that due to there being no
immediate Road access to the property a
careful construction management plan
will need to be implemented to prevent
disturbance to neighbors and allow safe
access of materials so that was from
councilor originally burnt and we
haven't had anything from Council of
Janet Pearson
um
I'll now open the item Up For Debate
councilor headingham
um I thoroughly agree with um what
councilor even says about the the
construction program but I'm very happy
with this and happy to um propose that
we um go along with the recommendation
do we have a secondar
councilor penny
uh does anybody else have anything to
comment on so as long as we make sure
that that construction management plan
is carefully worded
um I think we can and that's already in
your list of conditions thank you
so I will now ask the governance officer
to conduct the electronic votes
thank you chair members that both ready
thank you members to add those eight
votes for that's unanimous thank you um
so we now move to item 7e DC
230318 uh Gateway 14 land between the
a1120 and the A14 preaching St Peter I
will now invite the case officer Avril
Gowdy Gowdy or goodie Gowdy to introduce
the application to the committee thank
you
thank you chair good afternoon members
so the application before us today is
for advertisement consent for four signs
at Gateway 14 and the application is
retention of as you'll see the signs are
in situ
so just a reminder I'm sure most of you
know where Gateway 14 is on the edge of
Stone Market you've got the a1120
running to the western boundary Cedars
Park to the north
Tesco's McDonald's
ba14
Club Farm Barns and
mountains in the Best Western hotel to
the South
and the site location plan for that's
for the whole of the Gateway 14
development
in terms of constraints
um the sites obviously outside the
settlement boundary but you've got
um two grade two listed buildings at the
clamp Farm Barnes complex to the
southeast
and in terms of the site plan submitted
with the application
you've got just for some context the
yellow shading to the South is plot 4000
the range
um which has got permission is currently
under construction
and you've got plot 2000 to the north
which we currently have a pending
Reserve matters application in for
and then in terms of the location of the
sign you've got one sign
adjoining the Range site for the range
got a further sign to the north
and the remaining those three signs are
for marketing purposes of the rest of
the Gateway 14 development
um just for clarification because the
signs are referred to as the respective
zones and the planning permission refers
to the plots just
sort of for clarity Zone one refers to
plot 1000 zone two also refers to plot
1000 which is the green
the green and the light blue and then
you've got zone free which is plot 2000
and zone four is plot three thousand
and just to run through the signs so the
signs are 4.5 meters high measuring 4
meters by three meters and their
composite boards on steel posts so this
is the range sign
and then on the other
the other side of um Gateway Drive
you've got the sign for Zone one and two
and that's got the same dimensions
and the same with the zone free sign
and zone four sign
and then a couple of photos showing the
signs in in situ so this is looking
facing Southeast along Gateway Boulevard
you can see you've got the range sign on
the right hand side of the road and the
other sign on the left and you can't
quite make out the ones in the distance
but that's
that's the range
and then facing
the one that joins plot 2000
and then the other two either side of
Gateway Drive
so the recommendation is to Grant
advertisement consent with the standard
advertisement consent conditions with a
further condition requiring that each
respective sign is removed following
occupation of
the respective Zone
thank you
thank you uh councilor Lawrence
I can understand the need for the
advertisement signs for two three and
four because they haven't got developers
here people the range or known to become
occupied that's like why does it need
advertising
I don't know why they why they've had
chosen to advertise it
um obviously they're currently under
it's currently under construction
and we are requesting that once they
occupy that building which I believe
we're looking at possibly the end of the
year that they take that sign away
because they don't need it and then if
the range building wants its own signage
obviously that will be subject to a
separate application
councilor Mathison
yeah it suddenly strikes me that um I
bet it just um declare an interest as um
it's just as I I'm a director of the mid
Suffolk Holdings the message which is
actually is the owner of the immediate
owner of Gateway 14 Limited I don't know
what um the legal advice that we would
like to say about
and um
needs Suffolk holding zones Gateway 14
and the other companies
worth putting it in the minutes perhaps
yeah
I can't hear what what is the decision
about
sorry am I switched on now um I think
we're recalling we have had this
before predictably and given Gateway
14's making
it taken the wheel between us recalling
instances when members who had this kind
of involvement have declared it but
remained and participated
I was the same the person I'm happy with
that then
um you can you can stay councilor
Mathison
um does anyone else have any questions
um just following on from councilor
Lawrence's comment about I I too had the
you know why are we advertising when we
all we've already sold or at least that
plot
um how this is a retention so this is
sort of retrospective application do we
know how long those signs have actually
already been been erected
have they been there for before we
you know sold to the range
I believe they've probably been up about
10 weeks maybe
um yeah
so
I guess they just wanted to show that
they're um that they've got a plot and
they've sold it that maybe that's part
of an advertising campaign but that's
not really a planning matter that's a
sort of marketing matter I guess uh
anyone else got any anything to say
uh okay so um I don't think we've got
the parish Castle or an objector or a
supporter or an agent or a ward member
so we can open this item Up For Debate
counselor having a
hi I'm happy to um to go along with
second uh for that proposal Council of
War boys uh does anyone wish to speak
about the application Council Lawrence
I'd like to object the sign for the
range
as not as an identified need I think
it's disappointing the development of
that size and things that's being done
to even hear they've been up 10 weeks
already without having applied for
planning it can't be ignorance on their
part
and I think it's a point to principle we
should refuse the Reign sign and accept
the other three
but we we don't have that option we
either have to accept all four of them
or none of them but I I agree with you I
think it's very disappointing that our
Gateway 14 midsummit Holdings or whoever
it is who's put this up who's actually
in charge of the site uh hasn't got
planning permission before they erected
the site the signs but
um I guess that's just like any other
applicant that's not a reason to refuse
it but maybe that could be noted and
sent back to the applicant that it's
disappointing that even our own our own
companies can't do things in the right
manner
um but does anyone else have any
comments on the planning application
uh but yeah we either have to accept all
four of them or none of them so that's
what you're going to vote on um we've
got a proposal and we've got a second uh
so unless anyone's got any further
comments
um we will uh I'll see governments
officers to conduct the electronic work
thank you
thank you chair members that vote is in
progress
thank you members chair that's seven
votes four and one against okay okay
thank you
so um
uh we the final item on the agenda is
item eight which is site inspections and
we have now got a site inspection
um request uh for the previous
application so um the government's
officers will be in communication about
when that will be
um and it's a long time since we've had
a site inspection
um and the um
Parish Council and some of the
objectives were asking me what the
protocol was and I couldn't actually
remember so as long as we have a look at
it and make sure who's allowed to come
and you know they were asking I know the
parish council can come but I'm not sure
about anybody else so
um we've got that to come so look
forward to a nice day out in Brantford
um and I can now formally close the
meeting at 1642
um nicely in time for the 1721 train